evened up baby he the Gap
was even I just be hitting the gritty a
grim is shaking
fortnite a grim shaking
fornite a grim is shaking
fornite a grim is shaking a grim is
shaking a grim is shaking we let
the
baby that was so high and SK even night
and I should Beed hitting a gritty a
grim shaking
fortnite a grim shaking fortnite woo a
grim shaking fortnite woo a grim Shing
fornite a grim shaking a grim shaking
fortnite a grim shaking
fortnite
fornite fornite
[Music]
last a GM shaking
fortnite a GM shaking
fortnite a GM shaking a grim is shaking
a grim is shaking
fortnite
shaking
fortnite a shaking
fortnite a shing
fornite aing
[Music]
forite who wrote that the Jersey
lman you know it no for real who wrote
that L man woo did he really yes sir but
I said that as a
joke no he that's all him
the law man made that goated
bro what I didn't even know that dude a
video of him on his story this morning
uh shreddin yeah he he showed the
receipts well first of all welcome
everybody it is the H Street podcast
we're having too much fun today because
it is November 22nd and that means it is
our last day in the studio for tomorrow
is the wonderful day of Thanksgiving
that all Americans
love
um and uh it's a it is a most cherished
day and uh we're all just very excited
good news is for you guys yesterday we
filmed our traditional annual you laugh
you lose challenge video which is going
up tomorrow morning for
members who said I never did anything
for you
guys and then then on Friday it's going
to be flipped public for everybody to
enjoy yes
flipped we were originally going to do
it on Friday but then we said well why
don't we just treat the members you know
give a little something something so
that's going up on Thursday for all of
our lovely members and Friday for
everybody but it's another uh I mean
it's it's another treat it's another
treasure and it's a Thanksgiving Miracle
you know so thank you to everybody thank
to of all of our members thank you thank
you with peace and love of course um
remember it's actually a holiday today
too it is the biggest drinking night of
the year
baby yo it's the night before
Thanksgiving right it's the biggest
drinking night of the year isn't thanks
wouldn't Thanksgiving be the biggest
this is what we debated it turned out
Keem was right I'm I wait seriously
before yeah we all goofed on him but he
knows I think we found out guess we
should have believed him yeah as an
alcoholic I trust his
credentials bar night
baby anyone drinking tonight I mean it's
the biggest night of the year anyone
drinking no probably not wow we're so
yeah we're we so chill we are such good
boys and girls here at the we are just
daddy chill nobody nobody's even going
to sit back you are what are you
planning Olive yeah I'm going go out you
are yeah yeah with those glasses yeah so
are you going out to like bars with with
friends like what's the plan something
like that MH I just want I want to do
something yeah you're young you you know
what I mean I need to dance tonight when
I was just for the girls right yeah
absolutely and you know I know when I
was your age it's just like you want you
don't want to be you want to doing fun
stuff
M absolute so what do you do I've never
gone out in La um uh I love drinking
with my friends sitting down at a little
table with my friends dancing with my
friends we love friends they're the
bestall I love Dave and Busters I could
hit up D Busters that's fun
yeah awesome yeah uh to be young are you
drinking a lot of things that I no I
don't ever drink I only drink once a
year during our um our subathon
but I am working on a new recipe usually
during
Thanksgiving I'm the mashed potatoes guy
and I don't want to toot my own horn
although I do I will and I do want to
actually everything I said is
wrong um I make the best mashed potatoes
in the world and every and every
year people trip out and they lose their
minds over my mashed potatoes they look
forward to it this is why people come to
our home on Thanksgiving why haven't we
ever gotten in on that I can make them
that's a good point I'll make them for
you guys you brh potatoes get telling
you man there it's how much peppermint
do you use in your mashed potatoes is
the question well my recipe is
proprietary Dan but I'll tell you this
there is no Peppermint okay I'm in how
do you mash them do you use a Masher
mixer all by hand stick them in a stew
it's all by hand okay okay horsepower
Manpower horsep they couldn't be
creamier you know what I mean like a
machine can't do what I can do um maybe
I'll do that next week hook it up I'll
bring you guys a fresh batch of e that
would be fun creamy taters um but so
what I'm doing those because my mom
actually my mom my brother can't eat
dairy and then ela's Mom is kosher so
she can't mix Dairy and meat so this
year I'm perfecting a new recipe for
roasted potatoes and boy I'm telling you
this is nuts like people they do
roast potatoes all wrong these people
they throw them in the
oven they cover it in some oil they
throw it in the oven and they expect
that to be all you have to do I mean
it's psychotic it's so much more nuanced
than that first of all you got to boil
them so that it's crisp it's pillowy on
the inside there's nothing worse than a
goddamn poed potato that's not cooked
all the way through like Jesus Christ
now I don't know if this is traumatized
from because my mom has never been a
good cook or if this is common knowledge
outside of my family but you got to boil
the potatoes
okay and then into nice chunks and then
you heat a big ass pan full of oil in
the oven you take it out you put it in
the already hot oven and oil so that you
know you get maximum crisp time and so
that you want it to get crispy without
burning obviously we roast and you just
you keep turning it and mixing it in a
whole bunch of
oil right for like two hours and then
right before the end about 5 minutes
before the end you take this slurry this
uh olive oil Rosemary garlic salt and
you lather those up the
thing is you don't put it in more for 5
minutes cuz the garlic the Rosemary it
will
burn and that is Amateur hour and when
it comes to potatoes I don't
burn
[Applause]
and so this is what I'm working my
my goal is so that people they don't
think about the um mashed potatoes
everybody can partake and everybody is
going to say you know what mashed
potatoes is a thing of the past now it's
about roasted potatoes and who who can
relate
can I get a
way yeah that sounds great Sam what do
you think you're the only other like
chef chef in here I got a good process
for you oh really really yeah okay well
you should use duck fat for sure oh my
God that's that's pretty gnarly okay
duck fat Jesus wait I can't I'm making a
vegetarian I can't do that that's the
whole point oh dang okay I just use
canola oil well I like to uh
soften mine like boil them and then hit
them with like a glass like flatten them
out and then fry them in duck fat and
then you can put like your herbs and
salt on top it's I've seen have you had
those Ian
um I haven't made them with duck
fat but you've had that method with
bacon fat oh dude Sam you are a freaking
demon you know who had the duck fat
potatoes was at a Martin's restaurant um
yes at Gwen they they do make duck fat
potatoes this is what they end up
looking like I just looked up a picture
cuz like and I'm just telling you
man they're so good and I feel
like mine even look nicer than this oh
I'm telling you I'm telling you man and
boy howdy let me tell you something
man I'm ratat twoy up in this
right here boy Let Me Tell You
Man The Smashing is nice I like that
technique Sam I've heard I've seen it
I've never done it but I've seen it well
they're soft and they're crispy at the
same time so it's nice yeah I mean mine
are too Sam so let's just calm down okay
well let's see oh potato off next week
I'll bring potatoes three ways I haven't
third I don't know the third one yet but
I'll figure it out I'm I'm so in do we
have
a a uh Top Chef off potato off Edition
does any would anyone else compete in
that I'd love to
you good with really who I cook new
Challenger that surprises me we should
all bring our best potatoes huh yo
that's a fun for a little post
Thanksgiving uh bit next week on the me
show everybody bring your best potatoes
potato off o p you'll do it too I'll
join in oh it's going
down fuckud yes it's going I got I got
some good too I'll I'll join this
really I think what we have to do as
well is um we need to write down our
recipes so that people at home can can
participate if they so love it wow
that's exciting okay that's very
exciting anyone else got a um a
treasured Thanksgiving uh dish that they
cook annually traditionally $28 I always
bring the wine the wine you're the wine
guy yeah like respect $28 no matter how
you spend this is a lot for some
cookies it's $7 a bag and that's still
expensive but then you also have to
factor in that the bags aren't even big
to begin with it's 4 o per bag four o of
cookies for $7 is still a lot especially
when you compare it to the the product
that they're basing it off of and
supposedly approved upon those were $10
a bag for 14 o they offered you 10 o
more of join the Costco Costco a lot of
people really enjoyed them but most
people didn't like the price that was a
pain point of that $10 for a bag of
cookies is a lot so $7 for a smaller bag
of cookies significantly smaller a lot
too like it doesn't matter how you boil
down this math all roads lead to this
being an
expensive the brass that is a hard pill
to swallow it's not a hard pill to
swallow $2 for four pack of these
cookies isn't expensive it
is Jesus dude broke
Jesus all right don't call me
bro how dare you that's really about it
all right okay that's it oh that's excit
so nobody else Cooks from Thanksgiving
nobody else I'm making everything girl
of course you are I can't wait my
favorite is dressing I have the best
dressing in the world what do you make
what kind of dressing um cornbread
dressing corn what cornbread dressing
tell me more yeah what's in it I'll make
some well
cornbread cornbread
water I make like sourdough bread crumbs
and I let them dry out overnight and
then I make cornbread and I mix it
together with like a bunch of other
stuff it's so good I'll make I'll make
an extra one and bring it actually is
that an original recipe uh it is well
it's my mom's but yes wow
wow Sam it's
busting do you have any um do you have
any dreams of opening like a restaurant
or anything like that or you don't want
to deal with all any of that kind of
business
I mean it would be cool
someday I don't know I've always uh
envisioned like a coffee shop would be
really fun coffee shop yeah sandwiches
breakfast burritos would you make
breakfast burritos oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah you make sand
sandwiches sand swiches that's very good
I like my coffee do I like that that's
very good I'd eat there every
day what else are you making
Sam I'm going to make my corn
sule love that I'm going to make um I'm
also going to make hush puppies have you
ever had a hush puppy before is that the
hot dog in the what is a hush puppy
that's a pig and a blanket oh yeah um a
hush puppy is like a b like a ball of
cornbread dough that you fry it's
doesn't have a hot dog in it no and then
there's like you can put jalapenos and
cheese and stuff like that so it's all
cornbread I'm getting the put your balls
in mouth there's a lot of corn this is a
corn Centric meal I'm also I'm going to
make green bean casserole
and I don't know I don't know what else
I have a lot of things are you making
turkey no I think I'm going to do
brisket actually yeah dude I have a
uh I have a smoker and I think I'm going
to smoke a
o w whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa
whoa okay your thoughts Ian uh I will be
eating
probably tastes better than her food
from from yesterday that that you ate
dude were you kind of up from
yesterday we're talking about the vi the
laugh you lose that you guys haven't
seen yet for
the but yeah last night was your stomach
kind of or you didn't well I
guess no spoilers it's okay A little
spoiler I I laughed a lot and so I ate a
lot of really disgusting and I was
feeling a little rough last night I
gotta say but Ian did you how did you
fair
uh it wasn't too bad uh overall I had
some burps what what do you call them
sulfur burp ass Duty burps fart
fart mouth fart mouth over
here yeah but other than that it was it
wasn't too bad
um but I'm very excited to eat some real
Sam cooking yeah are you going to be
helping her inan or you just kind of
chill I'm sort of like the moral guide
poost I think in what does that mean
well I have this I have like a very warm
presence Ian likes to come in the
kitchen and go what can I eat like while
I'm cooking do you do you wish that he
would help you more or are you happy
with the current Arrangement I'm happy
with the current Arrangement you don't
want his help well our kitchen's kind of
small and I get overwhelmed if there's
like too much happening in it so I like
to just zone out and do my do my thing
and what you doating she wants me to
just get the out out and get away
she didn't inate that Ian she literally
said it yeah I mean just she said Ian
get out I don't
want yeah what you when you're in the
zone cooking do you listen to music do
you watch stuff what do you do I listen
to music mostly I have a speaker in
there nice yeah it's very Zen it's nice
Ethan got sutis would you guys stop
saying that that's not a real
thing yeah it's called Fart mouth that's
the science by the way go to Tedd
fresh.com we got our magic collection
up
[Applause]
magical stunning beautiful
[Music]
revolutionary so nice Street Wear AF
yeah that's happening at Teddy fresh.com
we also have Black Friday going on at
Teddy fresh.com we also have
uh the the cards are still
up very limited stock of the uh the red
ones left by the way that was the one
that uh we only had a limited amount of
the green ones are still available
though and those are a preorder so those
don't have a cap but if you wanted both
or you wanted the red in particular for
whatever reason time is quickly running
out think there's less than 100 left no
there's like 50 left there's like 50
left so Now's the Time and then um
pre-order ends December 1st on the Green
pack correct y so remember guys uh all
of the money goes to support the crew y
so go ahead and uh get some
cards support the team I'm about to do
all the red card owners a favor ready
I'm going to make it more limited Supply
what yo that increases the price that
increases the price bro that's true that
just increased the price wait which card
was that man that was a blank one oh it
was empty yeah it was a blank one still
though you sold a card it's here I'll be
I'll I'll put my money where my mouth is
where's my card no no no no no don't do
it C cam you lost it bro no no you can't
play it it's Cur dude no
Cameron don't do
it today guys the money the value is
going up what the fre the supply is
going down freaking insane bro I'm crazy
do not play this man all cut it put him
away cut it off put him away I am
cutting it off what do you mean no not
you cut stop showing this there's a
crime taking place man get your cards
today guys by the way some people were
confused about the the blank card there
is a blank card at the end of the pack
we added that because we thought some
people in the audience maybe want to do
their own thing post on the whatever uh
and the whole idea that started that is
because the whole pack is dude yourself
diyi and cuz we all made we all made our
own cards you guys can one too it's fun
yeah don't get mad about it I saw on the
subreddit that some people got some of
the autograph cards already or some of
the custom ones that we did yeah I think
somebody got Zachs right Zachs and Lena
and I feel bad for whoever got mine cuz
mine looked like mine was pretty
curs to my cards are very valuable I'm
so excited if someone got got mine cuz
there's a very funny thing on
yeah mine is just I took um a little
um of the glue stick and I just put
pubes and glued it to it so that's good
whoa nice little exciting treasure there
for somebody pubes on and glue stick I
mean what's a better combination frankly
than that it's up uh I didn't do
that for the
record all right so anyway we are here
to do a show today um
let's see we've got so much to get to
first of
all Tyler one he's a um Pro Gamer is
that right love yeah and he's a lifter
too he's a power lifter is that met yeah
and he's a he's I think he he's beloved
by all right he's pretty pretty
universally loved by yeah people like
Tyler one I think good friend of mine I
met him once he's a great friend of the
show actually but here he is
uh um giving
props to one of our very own let's
listen it is my to carry this started at
the beginning is that where it is no
yeah that time it's like 10 seconds no
yeah it is yes okay take no NOA wait I
got to listen to that guy's song again
actually that again my mind right oh
it's this here this you move uh Ethan
right I know the song I love it have you
heard this Olivia I have I love
it Olivia let me Focus up
please this is so
weird he loves it and this is what this
show does this is a song submitted for
Olivia when you're not there I think
about you always in my hair my head I
said it wrong again I'm stuck inside a
dream but
I all the comments are about this song
people are literally freaking
[Music]
out but this is this is the impact our
show has on the on the larger World
Community you know and this is why it's
an important cultural phenomenon here on
the a Street
podcast yeah so the question that we all
ask is is he a fan of the show or did he
find this by through some other means
why would he be listening I to this song
wondered myself I the only thing that
makes sense is that that fan who made
the song is also a Tyler one fan but why
would he even listen to it cuz he maybe
he did a Dono and said check out my song
or something I can message him about it
if you want he do that guy kind of looks
like a league player I got to be honest
I don't I don't I I got League vibes
from him
you look how bro look how in the zone
read them huh read them like a book wait
hold on look how in the zone Tyler
is oh that's another reaction me this is
1,000% we need this without the this is
live this is not po he's a very intense
young man that's a Pro Gamer yeah are
you familiar with this guy at all I know
a bit about him okay just that he's a
lifter and a character he's very much a
char
so
fun I mean he's in the Zone look at him
manast
music he just said
W so have you did you ever make contact
with him Olivia the boy who wrote this I
didn't
um maybe who knows what will happen in
the future so you I know that he's he's
at Zach show so I was just imagining
that I'll meet him there one next one
okay so he never reached out
he may have I didn't I'll be honest I
didn't look okay fair enough girl yeah
thanks girl yeah you're you know what I
mean you don't need you don't need to
I've been focusing on me you don't need
to look through that
um anyway let's just watch Tyler uh
play for a bit I should have been so
free actually what
the you know what I got to say instant
replay oh he's playing it again again no
dude this this gu
obsessed yes this song
is he gets in the Z it's on repeat baby
for the rest of the
[Laughter]
stream oh man what wait hold on okay I
have to disable chat because of this
thresh I'm trying to go pro on
this account mute all right we've seen
thank you Tyler all the comments are
about it though let's
see uh this song sounds like the start
of a Coming of Age high school movie
high school high school movie or
situational situation movie the
I mean that's true the song's a
straight Banger they says it is very
good it has grown on me I got to say
I've always liked
it uh for anyone wondering it's called
nightmare music video by Georgio
Peterson let's see if the let's see how
that song is popular George
Pon here it is
wait not Olivia okay 3,000 views that's
it come on man after the Tyler one
bump come on
dude all
right well just to as a side note give a
shout out to Jersey law
man this
dude well what did I type
180,000 views that's legit numbers
that's like billboard
ready I mean holy
[Music]
smokes yeah speaking of dream he's been
getting some hot water
right and I'm not talking about cheating
in
Minecraft I feel like every week There's
a new
dreamex story but I don't know how much
of it is real or not it's hard to tell
um um also like what just what happened
was there really is the H3 curse this
man calls in our show and literally as
he's calling in he's writing a letter
about new accusations which I didn't
even know what happening until
afterwards this man literally typed up
his his uh
his acknowledgement of the accusations
tweeted it and then called into the show
a
Nightmare a night man yeah but
um I guess somebody
leaked voice notes of
him I guess sexting frankly voice
sexting SE what do we used to call that
back in the day before it was just
voice phone sex PHX yeah phone sex I
guess sounds so like Antiquated weird
phone
sex but I don't know because it's still
used people say that people still say
according according to um dream who
calls anyone anymore not me I don't
answer my phone like right that's why it
seems weird it's like who's calling I
prefer to call well no he sent the
voice it's easier get done yeah
yeah you like you make people's day
that's right dude shout out to Trader
J here's the thing he sent it in a voice
note so that's
okay if it's a call that's different a
voice note is fine no it was a
uh was it wasn't it it was a Snapchat it
was a Snapchat yeah of course it was
God
so dream says and correct me if I'm
wrong some of you guys probably know
better than me um that it was the
recipient was a
um an adult and a consenting party to
the phone sex and he's saying that the
leaking of these is uh comparable to uh
revenge porn which may be so which may
be so so OB I'm not going to play it um
out of respect for potentially his
privacy I mean if it was a minor or if
it was unsolicited then I would play it
no
question but I don't want to proliferate
uh potentially what could be construed
as Revenge form right right I guess
that's fair yeah that would not be a
great look if that's what it turns out
to be but as far and you guys correct me
there's not been any evidence
conclusively that says that the
recipient was underage or unwilling
frankly I I don't I don't know enough to
be able to confidently I I don't want to
put out information if that's true Did
anyone look into it so when you was
looking I mean I I I saw what was posted
and in those posts you know it was like
a
Jesus people are so worked up about this
I'm afraid to say anything wrong from
what I understand it was anonymously
leaked to somebody who was from somebody
who's supposedly underage these voice
messages that are uh sexual in nature
hold on people are saying she's 17 she's
16 but how do you know 16 is the age of
consent listen we we we if you guys have
anything please share with us and if
listen if she's 16 I'd love to
know guys we're not we're not into the
dream verse as much as y'all in the chat
are so if you my dream my dream literacy
starts and ends with
nightmare the controversy was that she
said she was a minor okay so so
where I just want to know that before I
like put all that out there you know
what I mean that's a pretty serious
charge it is the biggest drinking night
of the year
so I don't know what the relevancy yo
it's the night for Thanksgiving right
it's the biggest drink of it's a minor
Ethan but tell me how do you know just
tell maybe we just shouldn't be talking
about it CU we don't know what we're
talking about we weren't planning on
talking about this today I want to know
and I'm saying I'm telling the people
okay if you know tell
me you know what I mean that's all I
want to know if you if you know send it
to one of the crew
um on Discord or
somewhere I'd love to know the the tweet
that uh is going around so that the
person was 167 year old in 2019 when he
was
20 and that's where everyone's the age
from but was the person that leaked
it just because it's legal doesn't mean
it's morally correct but if they're two
consenting
adults I don't know what was his age at
the time I guess I don't know in 2019 he
was 20 he was 20 and if if they're he
says they're 18 so I mean that's fine if
they're 20 and 18 right right
but but if you guys have evidence to the
contrary or you have evidence supporting
that they're a minor send it and then
we'll listen to that all day you
know what I mean I'll play that I want
to play it it's CRA it's funny it's
crazy he's like a moaning he
said some like I want to fill you
up princess as he was moaning I mean my
golly G Jiminy Cricket
man
um people complain they talk before
educate themselves on the topic yet you
guys tell them to talk well they haven't
done research just let just stop let
them research
first people complain they talk before
educating themselves oh well well I'm
I'm being transparent about what I don't
and don't know you know what I
mean
um
but I'm only talking about it because
it's the Talk of the Town and uh here's
dream right before me you
know you
know so that's what it is let's go I
mean he did cheat at Minecraft I don't
know what else that
means don't you don't you guys think if
somebody leaks
your somebody leaks your sex messages
as Revenge between two Consulting adults
then that is Revenge for no yeah yeah if
yeah if that's what happened absolutely
that I me that's not that's not cool to
do if you're consent if
something inappropriate was happening
then it's totally like yes
th% the problem the main problem is that
he is a mcraft
player and like statistically speaking
the odds are not in his
favor uh but I can't I'm not going to
play it until we know
definitively if it was uh you know what
I mean thanks thank you
dream
yeah he says he's making a video
response though so I guess I'll wait for
that when is that dude I want to watch
that right now send me that
preview
bro you take my
[Music]
hand people why you okay it people if
you're so sure it was on minor tell me I
don't think they were an adult Ean I
listen I don't I'm perfectly fine
accepting that but I'm not going to I
got to
know have a little more evidence before
I say the guy was texting miners I mean
with James Charles we goddamn know the
people go he goes age check and then
he's like 15 and he's like send dick
piics I mean you know what I mean like
that's easy yeah James Charles asks if
they are below 18 so he can talk to them
exactly what I will say is regard you
know everything that you said is true
and we should wait but regardless like
with James like with uh projared before
him
stop trying to your fans everybody
like please just stop doing like the age
thing is one thing and if that is true
that's up but even even if they
are adult like it's weird to be doing
that with your fans all the time don't
do that oh yeah you're setting yourself
up for disaster pretty much pretty much
that just just don't that has never
worked out go go to parties meet people
I don't think it's ever worked out ever
you know what I mean yeah just also it's
the serial like I understand you can
connect with a person who knows about
you who is a fan and then have a romance
but it's the serial dating uh that I
noticed too these people they like to
just
listen it's pretty obvious these people
become famous so they could just
dude you know 10-year-old fan right
away let me fart and let my farts or
wait no let my mouth smell like
farts
whoa I'm have the odds stacked against
me I talk about how I fart from my
mouth I've I've sabotaged myself
naturally from the beginning I could
never pick up a fan I burped from my ass
last night so you know you burped from
your ass yeah oh that's
interesting what was that like my tummy
was up you got that burp dude I
got bur you got burp ass that's good
good time great great way you know good
time someone said Drew Goodman's uh wife
was a fan I mean even I know that uh uh
PewDiePie's wife was a fan Maria I mean
Mar it's not like somebody who has heard
of you or has enjoyed your content is
like off limits forever but like if
you're seeking them out and like you
know what I mean if it I guess it's just
on a Case by case basis but like you can
doing it on Snapchat with fans all the
time is obviously not that that's it
it's the speed it's the speed sexting
yeah you can you can meet a fan and have
a meaningful relationship I mean EA was
a fan of mine and I wasn't even famous
at the time
so thank
you and I fan of
hers what the are we doing here
what are we talking
about playing the song Dream does this
thing where whenever there's an apology
explanation he writes like a 20 Page
essay I don't think I could ever read
the whole thing they're so long right
it's so weird he does that every time he
I feel like he just needs a video just
do a video sit down in front of
a camera and say what's up I think he's
afraid to do that because once you put
it on the
video it gives a whole life New Life to
it yeah for sure you know you
acknowledging it in like the most
serious way
possible yeah but
um I mean listen I wouldn't be surprised
surely it's just another Minecrafter in
a long line of many others who have uh
had a date with Destiny and in this case
Destiny being Chris
[Laughter]
Hansen there something about it what was
on the agenda tonight I mean you you
used to play Minecraft there's a
prolific like child
predator uh not I'm not saying I mean a
creator influ Minecraft influencers tend
to be some of the weirdest folk in the
world there's definitely a track record
of that 100% there been other
Minecrafter that are like doing creepy
stuff with Goods boy like a ton of them
I guess that would be the way to do it
right isn't the creator of Minecraft
isn't he into some weird is that
him not I haven't heard sexual propriety
but I know he's like borderline a Nazi
well he's crazy yeah so not only in the
child like Cal way there also just
generally weird people into Minecraft
for sure I I think you I don't think
it's unfair to characterize Notch as a
white supremacist right definitely well
no based on those tweets I'm pretty sure
he's just yeah is a straight up white
supremacist I I mean it's like Minecraft
you guys I mean what the is going
on in that game something's going on in
that
game you know uh we got to talk about
it the craziest one was lion liart what
was his
name bash
riverse lionart like is in jail I think
that guy was actually like a he's
actually in
jail yog cast I don't know what yog cast
did Tobuscus wait was toas is a
Minecraft
player I believe he was um Notch is
somebody said love Notch is Swedish
that's enough to convict what the
what are you saying gu seriously yeah
Tobuscus played Minecraft that's crazy
brother he is Swedish but he did move
out of swed and into LA and that's
started being weird he bought the most
expensive house in La history when he
moved here yeah it was like 180 million
or something it's crazy was that was the
party you you always talk about in that
house where I met log Paul absolutely it
was wow you want me to tell that story
again guys sure why not something about
California Pizza the kitchen and
uh meeting Logan Paul at the red Ferrari
mhm oh no my best friend passed away
last night I don't know what to do with
myself right now but the pot is keeping
my mind busy thank you guys oh no I'm
sorry about that I'm so sorry sorry not
Nate
damn sorry about
that don't play Minecraft whatever you
do stay off Minecraft is your
advice stay off Minecraft Nacho Man
that's all my only advice at this time
for you
brother grief sucks dude it's
the worst bro I you know what I mean
I I hope that someday soon your best
friend's uh memory
will I don't have any advice man I'm
still griefing my best friend dying too
although I don't know if that's the
comparable I don't know if that's
incense II to say I I feel that it
was sh I don't know if people understand
this when I say this Shredder was like a
human being to me yeah I get it do you
know what I mean I don't know if people
I definitely believe that yeah he was
your's first baby right
mhm I'm sorry
buddy can you play vamper's remix next
absolutely here it's on the it's on the
um suggested let's see 60,000 on hers
fantastic let do some juice too
absolutely it does
man I was groomed by a YouTuber if
youall want to hear about it just let me
know
Abby Abby Belle you and everyone else
Abby sure you got an interesting story
I'll hear about it oh yeah sky does m
Sky Does Minecraft
he went crazy I think he had legitimate
like mental health issues yes he totally
did it's very sad it what's up with him
I haven't looked into him in a while I
think he's off YouTube since last time I
like oh two months where have I been I
just came back oh how many views does
they have hold on
uh
145,000 again I don't know I don't think
there was any sexual impropriety charges
against him that I know of not what I
know
but but that's what's going on in the
world of
Minecraft you know there a crazy way to
frame it but yeah but yeah exactly yeah
I don't know man if a YouTuber if you're
just a normal kind of person and a
YouTuber is hitting you up bro your
Spidey senses best be
tingling yeah but unfortunately you're
probably young and you don't give a
or not I'm not even to put the the
blame on you you're probably young and
you know uh what's the
word
mesmerized yeah uh Jaden Kate just said
dream cheated at Minecraft that's the
worst offense in my opinion I um it is
pretty I've been saying this for the
last year hold on the the the cheating
thing is pretty instructive I think of
whatever he's doing cuz that was
bananas this man cheated in Minecraft
and then hired a
mathematician to write a thesis on how
he didn't
cheat
right and then and then he he later cop
to it right like that's the whole thing
he claimed uh it was like a mod was on
or something but it wasn't modifying any
game FS so somehow the this mathematici
crunched all the numbers didn't realize
that there was a mod on hey oh no
there's a
mod
yeah listen Minecraft series
business that's what I'm saying don't
you just speedr running in general this
is this is a sacred art form you know
here's a better speedrun straight to
Chris Hansen's uh
stool right all right let's get on with
it thank you let's get on with it real
quick I heard back from uh George
Peterson about the Tyler One Clip he
said he sent him uh okay there you go
that makes more does he play League of
Legends uh no but he says he uh does
lifting I guess he exactly he said
uh that uh I was on his stream in the
past doing lifting challenges he lifts
yeah he lifts you hear that Olivia
Olivia's in the bathroom unfortunately
he lifts he lifts he's up he wears lifts
he lifts and has a car God damn
yo anyway speaking of Jersey law man we
told him yo if you want to prove to us
that that guitar solo wasn't AI then you
need to send us the receipts and he
delivered here's the Jersey law man
shredding in
person here it is our
[Music]
boy Zach your thoughts
incredible fck
dude that guy knows how to sh
man he's hitting it like
[Music]
so that's just a dude who's confident on
guitar right yeah no he's
spectacular why is It sped up
though you know what I mean I don't
think it's sped up huh it definitely is
no no that's what I said that's I
definitely sped up it's decent the video
and this music is look at his fingers
strumming no that that's not a natural
it's definitely sped up you disagree in
that there's something fishing going on
I love the guy BR no he's playing but
it's sped
up does that mean he played it slower
and then up the tempo wait you think
it's sped up yeah oh for there's no
question about it in my mind the video
is definitely
altered it's sped up what does that mean
[Music]
Zach um
I love the guy I'm I'm not going to
on him um no no wait what does it mean
if it's sped up it mean if it if it's
sped up then he's playing it at a
drastically slower Tempo that's what
that's what I thinks
happening yeah but it still sounds
good I mean it's still he's still
shredding right
yeah yeah but it's definitely sped up
you
know but I mean he played it that's for
sure so there it is oh wait I think he's
in chat he said o bro bro it ain't sped
up what no way I don't think it's SP up
low frame rate maybe I think there might
be a delay honestly don't know what you
guys are talking about wait what I don't
want to be wrong so I didn't say
anything but it doesn't look look at his
finger it looks like look at his head I
think what the issue is it might be a
filter throwing the audio and video off
huh the audio and video isn't off either
I no no no it's not that it's his head
motions his hand motions everything is
unnatural like the the chord changes are
too
fast I wouldn't agree with that look how
fast his hand movements are it doesn't
it's unnatural but like the way his like
watch his hair sway it moves like the
speed of hair it's not like I don't
think like yeah because his hand's
moving fast no damn I I don't I don't
get what I don't see what you're saying
no even the headphone cord on his left
shoulder moves
unnaturally fast are you sure in my
opinion it might be because of a frame
rate issue it could be that that's the
only thing I can think of is maybe it's
a a weird frame rate so
it but you see it too AB right and me ab
and love we're kind of like the tech
Geniuses here abely
kind
of listen I'm one of Jersey Lawman's
biggest fans I don't think it takes
anything away from no definitely not I
just think doing a PO it's
overwhelmingly no it's not sped up he
said he said I 85% no he messaged me I
can send the video without the black and
white fil yeah yeah yeah yeah send
it and he says not sped up I believe him
I trust the guy well if he says so I
believe him look at blinking but with
his eyes let me look at his
blinking hold on it's normal I've seen
this
uh let me look at his
eyes they seem fast to me his eye
movements seem
unnatural that I mean that it's hard to
say I mean it could be a shutter speed
thing which makes things look more
Jagged and kind of unnatural like that
it just totally depends on the camera
settings but I'm not seeing obvious
signs of speed up would personally it
would be a lot easier if the uh dream
mask wasn't there and you could like see
his face clearly he's sending it right
now he's sending the sending the video
so but I've I've seen this call out
before a lot in the guitar Community
where they're like oh that's sped up um
oh really we should just have him call
in and do it live you
know yeah we'll have to put him to the
ultimate test yeah I can see it just
being a weird frame rate thing yeah I'm
sure I'm not here to hate it listen I
love the guy I'm just saying we all saw
it we all saw
it um speaking of that while we wait to
approve that uh you guys remember Pearl
Davis
who wish I didn't Pearl Davis she's been
like Absolut her YouTube Channel's been
permanently
demonetized and she has just absolutely
lost the plot people this her takes are
getting more and more nuclear as she's
becomes more desperate for attention do
you understand like you're not going to
be able to recover from this in any Walk
of Life ever whatever whatever your goal
is whatever poultry sum of money and
attention you plan on getting from this
you will never have a normal
life Jesus Christ at least someone like
Rush Limar or something at least they
actually have an audience and they're
making money you have no contingency
plan okay check this out man and
ladies this is a tough pill to swallow a
lot of your mothers do not want to see
you
succeed they want to see you just as
miserable as them so you can be her
emotional tampon the rest of her life
because a lot of your mothers have
failed again and again and again in
relationships and they do not want to
see you succeed there are just say you
hate your mom man I don't know what to
tell you this is posted on the masculine
mindset what do we what is this what are
we driving at mother drama have to do
with the masculine mindset it's just
about hating women the masculine
mindset I couldn't believe I was in the
barber shop and a bunch of The Barbers
were talking about how much they like
her oh God yeah wait what kind of Barber
Shop were you at what yeah it was just a
normal barber shop I don't know
how did why are they talking about P it
came up a video or something and they
were talking about it well unfortunately
her career is Mothers do want their
daughters to not succeed I hate to tell
you bitter pill swallow but your moms
are all
and they all hate your
[Music]
guts our mothers that are go ahead say
it say
[Music]
it you say
it now I'm not Hitler a good guy
dumb nasty I kind of to know
why God you are demented girl you're so
unlovable mhm mhm um I'll continue
simultaneously telling their daughters
that they love them and support them
while trying to ruin their marriage this
is common I would say this is more
common than is
not what does she know about literally
she's she's never been in a relationship
you are the singlest person in the world
what do you have to offer as relation
The 40-Year-Old Virgin woman's yes like
what imagine Steve Carell from the
four-year-old virgin giving people
dating advice that's what you're seeing
here in front of you right now it sounds
like a dumb person's idea of what a
smart person might say you know like
which none of this none of this is right
pearl or universally like what are you
are you hitting it some univ like yeah
maybe some some mothers don't like their
daughter I know whose mom doesn't like
their daughter her mom yeah right
exactly and
frankly MH mhm it's horrible to say but
I don't blame her yeah no it makes I'd
hate you too if you were my daughter I'd
be like this she up easy easy to
see the bun this this got half
baked we got to put her back in the oven
you know what we're reading between the
lines she might be ready to get
vulnerable tell us your story that's
what we want I tried I tried to hear a
story but all she ended up telling me
was that slavery was
exaggerated I tried to give her a
platform to share her
thoughts you
know oh God she's like oh she dated a
tick tocker okay yeah I'm sure that was
a really normal relationship no I know
about the relationship I know the guy
she dated actually it was actually I
like him angry reactions I I follow him
from what I understand their
relationship was like dysfunctional to
the point of barely being an actually a
relationship so I'm not
sure again good person to be given
advice mhm makes
sense I wonder what Charles Manson has
to say about the interpersonal
relationships I'd love to get his take a
lot of people loved him you know true
more than love have something to say I
mean he's got more credentials than
she does yeah no how to Wi you know
Charles Mansion P basically wrote uh how
to win friends and influence
people you know he's one of the great
social thinkers of our time anyway we
love Pearl and we kid Pearl because we
love her she has nine siblings no wonder
she does feels invisible she's probably
the shittiest dumbest one of all of
them they just they like that's mean to
say it is mean but she is mean it's hard
kind of that makes sense to me because
clearly she's grifting she's probably
waned attention growing up having a lot
of money and this is she found her
Outlet to get some eyes on her right all
right yeah something do that
perhaps oh excuse me we love Pearl I
have the law man's video I have to put
it on a Google drive because it's too
powerful in in Discord so I'm doing all
right so we got the original too
powerful
unfiltered filter we are going to get to
the bottom of this here today I want to
make it very clear with my claims I am
not doubting the Jersey Jersey Lawman at
all I just thought there was something
the video was low frame rate or
something threw it off a little bit but
I
think he would do that I no I know he
wouldn't do that he's a G I
didn't no first of I didn't think he was
doing it to intentionally mislead anyone
I thought it was obvious right I was
like oh he sped it up a bit yeah I
thought it was I didn't think the music
was edited I thought it was just the
video but yeah I wasn't committed either
all right here it is all right go ahead
let let me please you want me to open it
I got it okay I got it yeah I got it
actually it might still be processing
I'll download it it's all good
do you have your
passports uh $5 donation from the uncle
West I pooped can I get a shout out
shout out yeah hell yeah Uncle West
Taylor 26th birthday celebrating
watching the Pod awesome family members
recently we've helped them get through
it no one else I'd rather be celebrating
with happy birthday Taylor love you glad
to have you here cheers we love love oh
my God 300 from get the seeds right whoa
get the seeds right out of your sack and
bring them here 300 cuz I love you so
much I
don't okay trying to connect the yeah an
admirable attempt all right so here is
the unedited original jersey lawmen
shred
[Applause]
sesh oh yeah this looks
oh man he sh that's crazy yeah this is
real this is real right yeah yeah I
think uh there was a uh something in
that filter that was affecting the uh
kind of stutterin of it that was
throwing you off Instagram a lot
of up yeah I think it was just a
frame rate thing this guy can play
go
dude man you think that's why he has
long hairs at what because he Treads
yeah he Treads yeah dude it does kind of
Go part person there's some guitar
guitarists love having long hair
yeah why is that it's the look brother
it's the Rock and Roll Lifestyle brother
is it is it because you love the the
rock and roll stars of of yester year
personally me speaking uh I got a
haircut when I was younger like every
three weeks oh that's frequ so
like my parents were very clean make
sure you know I'm clean cut get a
haircut and when I got out of high
school I'm like that dude time to
Rebel Okay interesting um but yeah I
don't know I feel like long hair suits
me better oh yeah I like it yeah I'm
going to try to grow my hair out that be
saying this hair is not going to be cut
let the fro two years two years you
really you're I'll clean it up and stuff
sure I'm not going to but you're trying
you're going to go full poof two years
let's see what happens interesting have
you ever tried like straightening your
hair yeah it was a crazy disaster oh
we got when it gets long we should
try that one time I didn't I ever send
pictures of it my mom once tried to
chemically straighten my hair in high
school and I'm telling this is when it
was like all the way down to my chin
curly and it just it was so up
looking I got to see that let me see if
my mom has picked that I swear I thought
I on these nuts do we have picks of when
I when we
straightened my hair in hair High School
yeah I'm growing my hair back
people well there it is Jersey law man
we love you and we acknowledge
you
okay also something important that must
be said here at the at the I guess it's
not really the top anymore is it folks
but what it is is is that on Monday I
finally
um expressed myself and I said I called
on Netanyahu and the Israeli War cabinet
to cease fire now oh I see where this is
going I put my demands on them and I
said there's too much death there's too
much Carnage this is absurd not only is
it you're killing
innocence but you are also ruining your
own National Security interests we must
cease fire immediately what happens the
next
day what happened the next day the fire
the temporary ceasefire you did it
Israel has approved a ceasefire with
Hamas aldah set to bring a temporary
halt to the war so under the deal H and
people said oh what about the hostages
and guess what I said free the hostages
too and they listen to that as well
right that is the purpose of I said
Hamas free the hostages and
guess what Hamas is to Free 50 of the
240 hostages apparently lots of children
and uh
women so am I Gathering that you are
taking credit for this am I at at what
point am I not do credit for
this you know I mean how is this not a
Victory lap for me because people said I
wish Ethan would call a um here's the
top comment imagine Ethan had only said
this sooner damn shake my head oh well
then that kind
of I got point I guess they have a point
I understand when people are mad at me
because like I said that one comment
said I wish Ethan would calls for a
ceasefire so I could keep watching again
and um I guess I know what they mean now
yeah could have ended this war a long
time ago it's an historic day Ethan
should squeeze a bag of eggs for good
luck under the table every episode Jesus
alh grants a wish no but on on a serious
note this is good news and I may I hope
hoping it it extends to more than just a
temporary yeah Seas fire
and you got to call for it
okay right so do I do it now or at the
like day four like on Monday Monday is a
good vibe Monday cuz they're they got to
listen it needs to be timely if I do it
now they'll forget yeah right yeah it's
too
early I don't suppose Hamas does
Thanksgiving I don't suppose Israel does
thankgiving do they
right no so there you go not at all
probably not
I'm not going to continue that joke uh
premise I'm gonna keep
that keep keep that in the vault
anyways um age3 uh we have a new lupus
uh accusation let's
see not accusation well new lupus
receipts I think
here this is by we've gave credit to
this guys before the um H3 podcast
animated who it brings out bangers
always always
infrequently it's really up here
and here oh boy this ey isn't as bad but
and it by the way stting to get super
itchy too I'm literally itching my
eyeball look don't do
that don't do that don't do that do that
stop doing that hey don't do that don't
do that stop touching your
[Music]
eyes
there it is I love it he's out there
guys H3 podcast
animated like to give credit to all the
the fine artists in our community
they're great we love them um Brian
Johnson man I haven't talked about this
guy but I've been wanting to for so damn
long this is the guy who he's like a
billionaire I don't know how he made his
money he's a tech bro I know that and um
his new project is
knowledge
longevity and he treats himself like a
uh human experiment and he's trying to
slow down and reverse aging a lot of you
guys probably have seen him on on
Instagram I'm obsessed not because I I
mean his work is kind of interesting
frankly but he is a freak this guy is a
freak is this the one where he
talks about how he here listen to this
the biggest psychological barrier in our
current culture which is we perceive
inevitable death and so therefore
anything that happens like whatever we
don't care and so we have to overcome
and this is why I've been playfully
challenging the status and authority of
Jesus Christ whoa whoa I made a joke
that that Jesus fed wine and bread
accelerating
aging and uh in librating and I will
feed nutrients that will nourish and
create life why is Jesus the continued
representation of a philosophical group
of a billion plus
people why can't someone CH challenge
that status Authority and say no it's
not the resurrection it's not the
afterlife it's this life it's don't die
don't die don't die um he's got he did
last week he was doing this big
experiment on his dick it was like dick
week oh yeah yeah he was testing like
his erection strength and his his urine
stream strength and he was injecting
into his dick willingly and he was
like measuring how long he stayed hard
while sleeping oh yeah he he's obsessed
with how what percentage of his night
his dick is hard while he sleeping I
wonder how it measures that well they
probably put some electroid around his
deck clearly I can't bro yeah you know
what just occurred to me there's a
different Brian Johnson that's going
through a weird midlife crisis and his
the liver King oh my God he's also Brian
Johnson oh we got to get them in the
same room and talk about longevity well
they're like moving in opposite
directions right like he's like a
transhumanist and the liver King is like
a primitivist one looks back one looks
forward oh my God I would love can we
get that can we establish this combo
between Brian
Johnson's Bri this would be so fun okay
well we know liver liver's in for
anything and I think we can this guy is
pretty eager to talk to anyone Brian
Johnson here
um let's get them to
talk can we work on that absolutely okay
let's reach out oh my
God this has got me more excited than
anything this year maybe
perhaps
Primal
um oh you're getting are you getting big
timed by
liver it's been a few times where uh we
tried to reach out and uh he keeps
messaging me maybe I'll just message him
yeah that might be the best option here
look at this he's messaging you but then
his Zach can't get a hold of the man his
manager yeah hold on let me talk let me
see where where was he messaging me he
was trying to get me to come to this
event remember Instagram or maybe it was
email though oh that was
just I know what you're talking about
that was not a personalized mess I think
it was no it was he it was personalized
really yeah I thought he was just
blasting everybody no it wasn't just
that he he said your name in the voice
memo and everything too no right wait he
did say my name in the voice memo I'm
pretty sure
yeah The
Crucible hey Ethan it's been a long time
coming to repay you for your generously
hosting me and mine let's light it up
let's light it the up and have some
goddamn fun liver King
out it's not even a BCC it's just
straight to me out so here let me let me
write liver a email right now cu cuz I
don't want to forget and this is
actually really important to
me yo I just got some Intel bro I'm
Brian Johnson the futurist Brian
Johnson
what he grew up Mormon oh you got to be
pulling my
Johnson he's got such the Mormon
glaze uh at 19 Johnson became a Mormon
missionary customary for young men in
the Church of Jesus Christ of latterday
saints and spent two years in Ecuador oh
he's got to be out now though right uh
yeah it seems like yeah I mean he was
talking about challenging
Jesus fake Idol it sounds like he was
very religious uh uh in the past but
yeah he's got that ex Mormon glaze dude
it's like you said we should have
spotted it when you look at him he's
definitely glazed dude he's glaz as
hey l king would you be interested to
call in to the show again
soon would love to hear from you you
guys are talking about Brian Johnson the
lead singer for ACDC right yes let he
used to be a uh any other Brian
Johnson's in the audience reach
out maybe you can participate too we'll
get you in on this
debate here's one of his recent posts he
said my super blood reduced my dad's age
by 25 years my father 70-year-old speed
of Aging has slowed by the equivalent of
2 5 years after receiving one liter from
my plasma and has remained at that level
even 6 months after the therapy what
does this
mean it means give me some of that blood
dude this is giving
adrenochrome yeah completely well this
this young blood has been a pseudo
science for a long time like and it it
it comes back all the time in different
slightly different forms or whatever but
I think that I want to say this was like
a Victorian era thing where it was like
oh we can like inject ourselves with
young blood to like renew our Vigor or
whatever or humors this guy does seem to
be quite rigorous in the way he uh
scientifically approaches everything he
says the older we get the fast we age
after receiving one liter of my plasma
my father's now aging at the rate of a
46-year-old previously he was aging at
the rate of a 71y old I am my dad's
blood boy see why would you have why
would you say it like that you didn't
have to say that now before you ask me
for my super plasma some carefulness is
warranted only one biomarker is being
evaluated here there remains an open
question how long my dad's lowered speed
of Aging will persist so far it's been 6
months which is remarkable is unknown if
my dad's slower speed of Aging was due
to him removing 600 uh liters of his own
plasma or receiving one
liter of my plasma or a combination of
both my father didn't do any other
intervention during this
period I don't I don't even know what
here he is uh oh yeah he looks so
healthy he's forcing him to sit it looks
like he's comforting but he's not
letting him up yeah he's shoving him
down this guy is Patrick
baitman but I guess we're we're working
on a bigger piece about him so I guess I
don't want to go into too much I'm glad
he's doing this though it's interesting
it is frankly interesting he is a total
weirdo but yeah it's interesting cuz
he's doing it to himself self so he's
not really well and his dad but he's not
hurting anyone else and his son no his
son just his dad and son yeah yeah his
son is also getting he gets blood from
his son he he has his his son transfused
blood into him swear to God swear to
God also like he's weird
like his face does not look that good
and off he's wearing a ton of make he
looks like you know in uh in um
bloodborne which is all about like
giving blood to like heal people or
whatever all of like the bad guy like
their faces get all like stretched out
and kind of distorted from like the
weird alien blood spoiler alert sorry uh
that's going on he kind of looks like
that like he looks like he's being
infected by like a cosmic entity right
no he he does all this crazy work on his
face and skin and everything let me pull
up a picture one here he is getting
blood from his son will my son's blood
make me younger good question this is
him in a couple years
dude yeah well he's on his way that the
robot from Prometheus is what he reminds
me of David oh David yeah David that is
a car copy of him so freaky he's 45 most
people look really quite good at
45 the this idea that it looks like he
had a face transplant
is not working man this isn't face off
this is your real life dude there's
probably some photoshop going on too I
mean yeah and but he's wearing a lot of
makeup yeah look at that and his hair is
dyed for sure oh yeah not even a good
one you could tell boy but anyway we
love him I might just how much is he
worth what's his
story uh he's the founder and CEO of
Colonel a company making devices that
monitor and record brain
activity uh an OS fund a venture capital
firm that invests in early stage science
and technology companies yeah it's all
Tech related what's what do you sell it
for
uh let me know when you yeah we got to
we got to put a stop to whatever's
happening in Silicon Valley what's in
the water out there something it's
whatever is happening is the same thing
happening in Minecraft like we got to
figure it out there's definitely a
crossover that connect oh his company
was acquired by PayPal for 800 million
in 2013
okay wait he's not even a billionaire
then he's out here doing this kind of
and he does have a billion dollars
well that was 2013 now now I believe he
has over a billion isn't that fun how
money works like that yeah he's like I
got 800 million I'm going to spend like
a demon and then in 10 years I'm going
to be a billionaire very
good very good that's awesome was living
with my mom in Virginia and I had grown
up in a religion for all my life back my
dad
is
this I came to the California in my life
hey there's a delay hey tal well so I
was updating my algorithm of the number
of cameras on you so it seems like
you're doing really well I think so I've
been so proud of talage because he's he
has not been on camera at all he is not
youthful looking for 45 no that's what's
so interesting to me about I mean his
body's crazy he's like fit as hell like
so lean but his face and his hair
situation is dire he looks like uh Danny
Danny Elfman dude like he's a spitting
image of Danny
Elfman I don't know who that is from uh
you know oo Boingo night remember for
Christmas Danny Elfman let's see I'm
surprised he hasn't had a oh yeah I see
it a hair
transplant he might have but he needs
another one he looks like my grandma
just got like my grandma straight from
the perm store he has so thin hair looks
like and listen uh you know God bless
man but if you're going to come out here
like you found the Fountain of Youth
don't be out here like you just got
Nana's
perm God he is eyeing his son like he
wants that blood his hair his son has
beautiful hair actually stunning yeah at
all and talent is learning
extraordinarily fast I'm impressed we
are on
time there's an epic shot at 6:55 Hal
nut Nutter Butters snack size and then
cookie size Oreos e and you know what he
does with this option set we will choose
nutty oros are in a big part of the
blueprint you just want to check in Self
Service there are so many things that
can go wrong we've a load of this guy
this entire thing to happen in 24 hours
not a single thing can go wrong so I'm
pretty nervous about this I'm actually
excited this is like the first thing all
right get on with it what are we doing
here why do we need to travel to get
some blood I'll get some blood from I
know guy I'll get a blood for the end of
the day that was a beautiful moment that
I will never forget where do you want
yeah go ahead next to Tage okay B I get
a lot of meanness directed towards me
for project blueprint it does something
special to just get under people's skins
they seem to just boil and they want to
just unleash on me I do have to confess
I do love it all right let's do the
first one I hope he gets hit by
okay well come on that's mean he'd
probably be fine though that's what's
interesting about project blueprint you
think he bounc right back the bus would
bounce off him and he would continue to
walk the thing on this though I wonder
what happens if a bus gets hit by Me
Maybe he chokes on a piece of broccoli
or mushroom I mean that's kind of funny
maybe that would be pretty funny way for
him to
die this is actually legit
there's there there's so much irony in
life and if I were to die it would
probably be choking on Broccoli I like
how it goes if I were to die like he's
not sure it's ever going to happen it's
a debatable we might not die we'll see
but he he he's a good sport about
everything obviously he gets a ton of
scrutiny and cuz he's such a meme
but he's a good sport and we like that
he's a good sport good
comment but I don't know what's the
point of this video dude what what what
part did you want me to watch uh uh AB
Olivia the time that time time stamp
was well I was going to send you at 655
there is a epic shot of the him and his
father and his son to do is get pictures
there's only uh 20 minutes of sunlight
left and also my bedtime is fast
approaching and I just don't negotiate
with my bedtime ever and actually go
physically go pull them up pull them up
Richard I appreciate
you
cool you look
great dad you want to take Center if you
had to summarize what would you say you
can think about this as things an
individual can do to be healthy and well
we typically think about it as an
individual doing something but rarely
this so much leg happening which I I
mean look at Grandpa's not shy at all
grandpa has nice legs actually mhm maybe
there's something to it give me some of
his blood his legs are young mhm least
yeah they
are it's such an interesting guy but we
we're actually preparing a larger bit
about him so we'll see we'll see we'll
talk about it then holy God Simon cow
let's take a look at Simon cowl and see
when his face started to change the
answer will shock you all dude Simon Cal
dude what happened brother estimated
cost before and after will be revealed
at the end well I just want to go to the
end I I don't need all this show me
the before and after go ahead Dr Gary
linkov is
$210,000 and here's what it be $210,000
will look like
that sign me up he looks good there's no
way that him normally
aging wouldn't look better than this I
don't I don't know Po and after looks
like since you like this video on Simon
Cowell make sure to check out our other
video all right dude stop
stop it um let's move on thank you Brian
uh we look forward to look deep doing a
deeper dive into you later thank
you Grandpa's got some nice legs though
mm you said it Granda is feeling a
little frisky
today um I'm gonna have to ask Mike
Lindell who's now a fan of the show
about this claim um this is some guys
I've talked about them before but I'm a
fan of their work they're quite funny
quite good big news oh boy
Ethan I see on Tik Tok uh the account is
the good liars yeah and um they go and
interview Maga people mostly thank you
Sam yeah they're great um but this guy
had a really interesting take about let
Mike Lindell here Mell who is is John
John still alive we're going to find out
the truth so you think you think that
Mike Lindell is John F Kennedy Jr
yes I do we're you have a you have a
picture to prove it there so this is a
picture of Mike Lindell and John F
Kennedy Jr and so what's what's the
evidence here well the evidence is we're
going to find out that people had to
play certain roles to get the truth out
to people so why would John F Kennedy Jr
fake his own death and then assume the
identity of a Hello salesman well you
have to ask yourself what was he running
for he was running for a seat in New
York who won that seat was it Hillary
Clinton John F Kennedy Jr is actually
Mike Lindell we'll find out we'll find
how we gonna find out I'll find out I'll
ask
him I gotta ask him this
is Mike Lindell are you JFK
Jr you want me to email his
assistant just that well I want I got to
get him on the
phone yeah
fun good
times
um by the way new friend of the show
William the uh Film LA what was his name
of his Tik
Tok uh film the robots La film the
police LA and uh Street or Street the
streets La this guy's awesome he called
in the show last week such a character
smart guy actually and doing really
interesting activism here he is uh
getting into a confrontation with a
Scientologist outside of the maybe
potentially Scientologist I mean he's
way too defensive for a normal guy he's
got some elron hubard thrown through his
vein I agree but just not entirely sure
anyway here very bad C man Street La Tik
Tok you a Scientologist too oh man we
got another Scientologist
grinning I can take that phone and break
it on the concrete your
skull is aat want is that a
threat is that a
threat you know what you made why you
different there is a criminal threat
that's a criminal threat you go to jail
for that he yeah yeah yeah have a good
day yeah yeah I'm a criminal huh I'm I'm
the criminal well I mean yeah if you go
ahead and break my or you threaten to
break my phone that's called that's
called the the first amendment I have a
right getting do you see do you say
you're asking a question you're
bothering them too bad it's called the
First Amendment it's protected by law
person I have the first right to speak
out against a cult if you want to defend
a cult knock yourself out why don't you
on your own life I'm working on I'm sure
you haven't done for yourself bu
that's why you had the Band-Aid on your
face you couldn't even afford a whole
Bandit you had to do a half one who
switch your yeah walk away walk
away walk away and get those SC what's
with those scabs on your leg what's on
your leg needles isn't it needles
needles needles somebody your
head criminal threat is that a criminal
threat do you want is that a criminal
threat I threaten criminals I threaten
criminals that's a criminal thre that's
not what the law says see even Isaiah's
freaked out even Isaiah's freaked out
look at isah you scared the Fu
about your
godamn you're getting very wored
up wait there was part two uh he never
posted it or something or maybe it got
removed I went to look for it and there
was no part two streets La wins again
the robot part at the Isaiah the robot
comes up scaring
Isaiah that's the face of a
Scientologist if I've ever seen
one and really the half Band-Aid was
that's a good pretty good observation
there what happened there
buddy is that what his legs was I don't
know what's with all the scabby on the
leg is that a that's more meth thing
using yeah and and how why does meth
cause that it it's called ice gabs a lot
of math addicts will like excessively
pick at stuff or oh they just picking at
their legs yeah are they is it itchy no
it's just they want to do something
you're just jittery they're fting and
also um Scientology is the founder of
narconon too so I don't know if there's
any correlation there so maybe the
founder of what they they have an
organization called narconon which is
you know oh they have a rehab yeah thing
so I don't know I'm just speculating
there but an adct there could be a
connection there okay
well I wish that guy uh success if he is
looking for rehab and I will say this
about
William William stays winning and that's
streets of LA for
you he has yet to take an
L um oh God are you guys really want me
to talk about this one this point number
five hold on let me see who wrote
that I don't know I was curious too some
Maniac added that who was it not it no
ghost was that you Dan I might have
added it we don't have to talk about it
we don't have to talk about
it I I don't I'm not saying I did I I
don't remember putting it in there but
let me take a look at this H I don't
know if I want to get into all this I
don't move on I'm sure I don't
yeah peace and
love let's not make any uh do anything
that I'll regret here today thank you oh
Olivia speaking of
um wild
messages I don't know if I spoke of it
before beautiful segue so so you got
this is just unol ited Instagram oh yeah
DM yeah yeah yeah I got um a pretty
poetic first message from someone and
then they clarified very uh specifically
what exactly they were
saying you want to read it I would yeah
absolutely I will read it you're got it
so I posted like a cute little selfie
and um this person responded be honest
what would it take realistically to go
down on you personality-wise we aren't
compatible but I mean I would make you
come like five times in 15 minutes if
you would give me one chance that's all
I ask and then he said and by that I
mean I'd eat your just
saying that is so vile I was so offended
that he thinks we won't get along what
the is the problem yeah I saw your
tweet I thought it was very funny thank
you thank you very much she said uh I'm
offending thinks our personalities
aren't compatible I can get along with
pretty much anybody
literally especially if he made you come
five times least of my worries yeah I
can make you
giggle what do you do here what do you
what you do you block do you accept do
you um you read you read you move on and
you show your you show your friends is
this a rare type of message I don't look
through my unsolicited you get stuff
like this I do get stuff like this my
god dude yeah it does I mean I don't
like it obviously but like it doesn't
hurt me it's just the internet yeah it's
just silly yeah silly
business but you think I wonder if he's
being totally serious where he's like
I'll do this maybe I should take I
should show me maybe I should just see
what happens yeah yeah okay just okay
that I think that that would be the the
correct plan of
action the
test well did you guys check do you guys
get unhinged
messages yeah or is this a ladies I used
to more when I first started I don't
know I think because Lena wasn't on the
show at the time people didn't know I
was married and I get some wild
really mhm look
what random messages like really expli
explicit nudes um I I quickly learn not
to open the photos yeah
I do open the photos I look I mean yeah
I mean my eyes are curious what can I
say you're
there it was like them describing what
they would do to you sexually like that
kind of thing AB or
what um yeah yeah it's been a while
you're going to look so hot I mean half
the time I would I would just me and
Lena would look at them and laugh but
yeah to put it on you I don't think I
get lots of wild but I mostly just
think it's funny oh my God you
degenerate in the audience you
freaks holy crap I don't look at my
messages but me neither me neither I
don't even go there if you sent me stuff
there sorry I haven't seen it they scare
me so I don't open my DMs so many nudes
in your uh no I got a I got a death
threat once so I just was afraid to open
I don't know what they why did they want
to kill you I don't know any number of
reasons I don't I can't say I blame them
but uh I've just been afraid to open my
DMs ever since you do not deserve to be
murdered
cam wow nope I can agree with that thank
you for saying so you guys are so sweet
to say so I always got your
back thank
you um well
murderer shout out to the uh crew and
the audience who are having really
wonderful interactions
here wholesome
interactions he sounds like an anti fan
though he's like I don't think we get
along so he's watched as an anti-an and
he's he's had Amorous thoughts about
you so there that
is uh let's get to the main part of the
story here and this is all really
important stuff so you guys have heard
me talk about psychologists in Seattle
this guy is a world-renowned
psychologist
therapist I believe he's written several
books and 's got a Peabody and as well
as a
um jinal medicine award and
a a Nobel Peace Prize I think as well
really yeah he's a big deal they won the
Nobel Prize so he gave um Colleen an
apology analysis he gave her a
D+ okay now again just as
a just as a reminder I don't believe I
ever
watched
he shouted me out in the apology
really hold on well you are the king
this the the first apology that she did
not in the most recent one okay yeah so
again once again I just want to remind
he gave me a A plus 10 out of 10 apology
and listen I'm not using that to feed my
ego or anything I'm just saying
that yeah you when it becomes to
apologizing I am the very best
yeah you're very humble and I have
probably practice the most some say some
say the humblest mhm yeah I would coming
from my stick Dan that's not
your stick the is that dude that
was my he's right Dan you're stepping on
his toes mhm back off dude wait why are
you confused that was my shtick with you
no that was your shtick yeah no it
wasn't H some say the most
sticky the
stickiest uh gosh we someone's gonna
have to go the audience always has the
receipts so let's just see some say the
most the most receipts now you guys
whoever commits bigger to the bit gets
it some say the biggest some say who it
commits the
biggest anyway here he is talking about
my perfect apology in reference to her
last one go ahead uh well Trump's
apology was zero morson zero
accountability just like well that's
just locker room talk that kind of thing
just making excuses justifying it so it
wasn't as bad as that so but let's look
at D A lot of them are d a lot of the
public apologies I'm usually debating
between dnf I'm just realizing this now
except for Ethan Klein who I think I
gave an A+ to because it was it hit all
the points I can't remember the whole
thing but okay so D the average public
apology so that if you get a A+ apology
it's almost better it says bet like I'm
glad I said what I said in the sense
that it just I got opportunity to show
what a great guy I am hell yeah cuz like
if this is was about the chestnuts thing
the apology and as terrible as the
chestnuts thing was and how regretful I
was about it in the end it did kind of I
mean I did get this A+ out of it and so
in a sense do I regret it
now I do still regret it I do still
regret it mhm
but there's a silver
lining a really bright silver lining so
much so that it almost eclipses the
darkness blinding blinding Silver Lining
this so
bright uh
warming oh yeah so this is the average
but minimally met some of the
requirements you could say yes lack of
depth yes lack of demonstrated remorse
okay yes all right so according to my
criteria let's give her a d maybe a D
minus cuz
so woof that's broodal these nuts so
let's see what he says about our new one
and if you guys are interested we can
watch this analysis of mine that'll be
up to you guys you know um but let's
let's take a look some say the lookest
hey deserv and listeners a lot of you
have been asking me to react to Colleen
Ballinger's new apology video I'm
curious what she has to say if you
remember she has this is hot off the
press 5 hours ago
yep calling Ballinger second apology
analysis therapist reacts that's H don't
sell yourself short man tell say like it
is
Peabody
award-winning
humanitarian does he have a peot at
least
one wasn't sure if some of it was true
but the Nobel Prize was just where you
started doing that great but that's
obviously silly but he does have a few
PE bodies with him they won the Nobel
Prize before we get into this did you
see the notification some people got for
our episode today no I sent it oh no oh
come on YouTube really sex Colleen
Ballinger apology anal I mean come what
the hell that's so funny
seriously not what we meant that is not
appropriate for any age say most not
inappropriate someone say the right
thank you and just for the record I did
steal it from Dan did you know that wait
you're reversing course now I never I
never
oh what wait wait wait wait wait wait so
wait you know you stole it from Dan yeah
I mean he stopped doing it so I just
kind of became a bookmark for it
whoa so hold the phone I was questioning
you were gaslighting me dude I was
questioning my sanity I'm like I thought
I used to do that all the time he did so
you're saying you you just picked up the
slack cuz yes I mean that's fine I I
don't object to that but don't try why
you call me out for I'm I'm just trying
to I don't know where's my apology I'm
sorry someone say the
sorest so wait can he pick up the slack
Dan or can you guys share this I'm happy
to share he was the one that came for me
I was just trying to get you I'm happy
to share Zach you did you said you stole
my shti I'm sorry I was just trying to
get your I forgive you it's all good all
right it's all good someone say the
sorest someone say the most
sorry all go ahead um go ahead Seattle
psychology and whatever
proceed had a different apology video
from a few months ago where she was
playing the ukulele it didn't go over
very well with the public let's watch
Hello everybody uh sorry I've been gone
for so long I've really missed this I've
missed talking to everyone every single
day um obviously the last video that I
posted on here um it's really
embarrassing to say the least
I was being accused of some pretty awful
things and I just was mad and um I
should have handled that situation with
maturity and empathy but instead I just
let my ego take over and I'm really
disappointed in myself these apology
videos are usually pretty brief so often
I have to almost read into the things
that they're saying because they don't
elaborate let's go phrase by phrase It's
really embarrassing to say the least
I was being accused of some pretty awful
things and I just was mad and um I
should have handled that situation with
maturity okay so the first thing that I
look for is is she sincere is their
sincerity that's in the eye of the
beholder none of us can read her mind
contrary to what body language experts
will claim there is no way to read
people's minds or eye movements to
detect whether or not someone is telling
the truth so I've been developing this
checklist over time because I've watched
a lot of public apology videos by this
point so the first thing is what was the
transgression exactly I always or
frequently I will go to Reddit and go to
the subreddit that is called out of the
loop they say colen Ballinger is known
for making goofy videos as Miranda sings
That's the character and her Channel
know and
one communicating in ways with miners
that people that and kids that she the
like a
understand all right here I think we
have time stamps yeah we
easierly suit our
needs let's see here makes sense to me
it's really embarrassing to say the
least
I was being accused of some pretty awful
things and I just was mad and um I
should have handled that situation with
maturity and okay so we hear her saying
that she was accused of something so she
she's not saying that she did something
and that sounds like exactly my where's
my peab buddy right we're so keyed
up um exactly I mean I think he must
have watched our
analysis yeah yeah and based off yeah
you got filled in mhm she actually
filled in and in the case of dream
filled up princess oh
stop stop
why disgusting fill me
up F that princess up no right
now right now is not admitting that she
did anything wrong it so far all she is
apologizing for really is the previous
apology video that it was embarrassing
to her I should have handled that
situation with maturity and empathy but
instead I just let my ego take over and
I'm really disappointed in myself okay
so that's actually pretty good she's
acknowledging I should have been more
empathetic do you believe that she's
being genuine hard to know the problem
is here um psychology in
Seattle she's saying just call him
Frasier Frasier what is actually his
name Dr Kirk Dr frer crane Dr Kirk Honda
or Dr
I like Dr Kirk that's pretty fire that's
that's got a nice rank to it Commander
Kirk yeah can we call him Commander cap
well he was a captain and then he was an
admiral Dr Admiral Kirk oh Jesus
wait Kirk was he was a
captain and then he got promoted to
Admiral later in the series spoiler yeah
spoiler over it sorry you're talking
about Kirk he was a Admiral whim in the
movies oh later like after the original
run of the series well you got to be a
captain or he he's known as being the
the first uh officer captain no he he
was the captain bro what are you talking
you got to be a commander before a
captain so Kirk yeah isn't Spock C is
the captain what are you saying these
are different series Kirk is from you're
you're confusing Kirk with rker aren't
you Commander rker who's Kirk dud Jesus
Christ dude I even watch the show I know
who Kirk is oh that dumb ass brother
this guy okay never mind he's the OG
dude bro Star Trek original
series is goated man dude I'm watching
it right now oh you're watching it now
yeah I've been watching it for forever
I'm converting everybody into trekkies
in this office I've been a treky oh you
been a I watched I turned to the dark
side man I it's so good y here he is
making out with the alien oh wait no
that wasn't the bad one here this is the
one he apparently this this thing
no he sure yeah he that he
it yeah yeah you're right KK
everything Spock just stands I don't
know why I I Had a Brain see that right
there uh kissing uh Ur that was the
first interracial kiss on television in
America seriously dude that show is so
Progressive it was actually it was a
very Progressive show what do you call
this was this the first inter inter
species as well yes yeah do you know
what year no man has gone before uh what
year
I don't know exactly 67 right yeah mid
60s you know a lot of people hate
Shatner though he is has a legendarily
large ego but he does he's the he has a
lot of redeeming things about he
an alien on television that's true
waight oh Lord all right Jes Captain go
ahead go
ahead
[Music]
um
so here's what I want to say today um
over the last 15 years of my career
there have been moments where I was
immature and inappropriate with some of
my comedy and there were times when I
did not put enough thought into some of
my fan interactions okay so that's
acknowledging it depending on what she's
referring to but I think that's pretty
solid acknowledgement that she's saying
I was inappropriate with my fans the
problem is she doesn't get more specific
and she leaves it very open-ended is she
talking about her interaction with Adam
she talking
about you know enabling her brother
who's an actual like pedophile Predator
to prey is she talking about when she
you know um cuz she characterized the
fart thing that she did to um what was
her name Becky Becky as just a fart joke
so she talking about that we don't know
what is she owning up to we don't know
she's leaving it up to our
imagination to figure
out without having to own to apologizing
to anything
really come
on I think she could really drive it
home by identifying an example or by
saying I was inappropriate with miners
over the last 15 years of my career
there have been moments where I was
immature and inappropriate immature and
inappropriate yeah those are good
descriptors again I'd love it if she G
us gave us an example I'm guessing she
won't some of my comedy and there were
times when I did not put enough thought
into some of my fan interactions and
because of that behavior people got hurt
that's good you if you believe her even
halfway then that meets the definition
of an apology you know that she
acknowledges the harm that she caused
she's not blaming it on anybody else at
least in this moment and she's saying I
was
inappropriate and immature with my fans
and I didn't she says I didn't give
enough thought to my interactions with
fans yeah it's certainly not as
descriptive or as harsh as the way
everyone else puts it right yeah she
could say something like I was in
appropriate for example I sent a pair of
bra a pair of bra I sent a pair of
panties and a bra to a miner who was a
fan who who was a minor now when you
hear that to me it sounds worse than it
actually was it's still bad but what
actually happened and I remember
watching the video she is doing a live
stream and there he got gas lit by her
yeah think it did because I I got got by
her too when she explained it I was like
oh this whole thing is
dumb but the context of it
all you got to I think we need to rate
his his analysis you think I'm have to
go come down harshly on see and seek
psychology in Seattle we can't even
curve the grade bell curve
him
damn I guess we could bell curve him but
there's not much of a bell I mean he's
the first one he's the first therapist
on yeah yeah he got gaslit though you
got got brother there's a lot of people
watching and you know chatting and
chatting and she was with one of her
colleagues and she was unboxing new
clothing items and she would take out
like oo these pants are silly they look
funny and then she would put them on her
head or whatever and that was part of
the the charm that people were looking
for with her and something I've always
found like weird about the pantties
situation is she always refers to them
as like the ugliest like pair of
underwear ever but it's like lacy like
lingerie not part sexy it wasn't like
Grandma no it's like that that's
real like sexy lingerie whether or not
like you want to call it ugly it's not
outwardly ugly it's more sexy than it is
ugly definitely definitely and I mean
this isn't a random kid this was a kid
that she
knew intimately had a close relationship
with I mean what the I don't care
how silly is is you don't send lingerie
to a child MH and he was very much a
child I think he was like 12 at the time
literally um but again when I heard her
explain it I was also like oh okay MH so
we got to we need to get in touch with
them we need to get him the facts the
details
um let's see the analysis and
comment and within that pile of a lot of
different garments there were unused
panties and a bra on the live stream she
said okay who who wants cuz she was
sending these items to to her fans and
it seemed that to her fans it was this
wonderful offering because they would be
able to have some connection with her to
be sent an actual item from one of the
videos
you know they would frame it or
something um which you know I I get it
it wasn't from a video I have my Paras
social relation like a prop and one of
the fans said was like a historic prop
it was like discarded lingerie yeah they
were just going through all of her
Forever 21 purchases and she didn't like
them
brother oh brother the bra penties and
she joked around and said okay I'll send
it to you that's a lot different than
the way it sounded at the first time to
me you know it's a lot different than
she had her own used panties and bra and
she as a way of soliciting sex or trying
to suggest sex to a biner she sent her
own garments to a fan who was a child
well that sure that would just be like
go to jail right I mean that's just like
yeah we're just going to we just put you
in prison
now sure it's not that bad but as a
pattern of behavior m
you know really weird for someone with a
child audience one of the very many data
points that Pro to right her whole light
is like a
uh what do you call those night brights
you remember the night brights oh light
brights right yeah you connect the
lights yeah my sister had one wow that's
her that's her her me and my sister had
one actually her hav't thought of that
in Forever career is a checkered like a
nightlight
uh why did I think of that the most
Boomer reference ever I don't know why I
with those though I could get my
kids one they still sell them do they
really still thing yeah I mean they're
sick why not I guess so it's called a
night bright light bright light bright
light bright light brights and easy
baked ovens those were the U had easy
you guys remember these did anyone
so fun so cool Teddy would love those a
I got to get some of these here I got to
get a light bright dude hold on let me
send this to ELA
got to get a light bright dude has Teddy
done ET a sketch I loved that too yeah
sick um Ted by the way Jack's Belgian
waffle gifted US 10 podcast memberships
so thank you so much Jack thank you big
fan of a Belgian waffle here thank you
so much big fan waffles are pretty go
dude you give the gift of you laugh you
lose
actually Jack right um Jess favro said
it's my boyfriend David's birthday today
and we're watching together love you
guys shout out to um
David and Jess Taylor Johnson said
today's my 26th birthday I'm celebrating
by watching the PO I've lost two family
members this month
Jesus but you guys have helped me
through it no one else I'd rather
celebrate with Taylor 26th birthday
geeez Louise
man two family
members how ended would you say family
member like cousin uncle aunt what about
like second cousin I it's so
circumstantial right it depends if you
grow up with your second cousin yeah
then it's family but if you like meet
them twice in your life you might not
think family count that doesn't count
that doesn't count you're not related
anymore I'm so sorry gez what a what a
rough month but Taylor uh we're here we
love you thinking of you God
damn somebody said they had a lightbrite
when they were a kid and they're only 19
years old so I guess I was totally off
base light bries are still killing it
out there dude killing it that's nice to
hear Brother Jasmine says oh my God I
love psychology and Seattle thank you
for giving him some light he's amazing
Dr
Kirk here they
are the two Originals the greats the
greats Captain Kirk and Captain Bard
together at
last uh
yeah these are super fun you turn the
lights off it's got like a back lit
they're probably even better today you
got like super bright LEDs blast true
through there you know true I got a
light bright
app it's not the same it's fun to have
the tactile little the little peggies
and pop it through do you guys remember
um light brights in Boston that whole
thing that was a conver
do that was the The Adult Swim like
terrorist bombing thing yep wait light
bright in Boston so Adult Swim they were
promoting the aquatine Hunger Force
movie I believe it was the convergence
of all my loves Boston Adult Swim light
brights there you go they shut down the
city cuz they they put him in weird
spots and they thought it was bomb it
was like a viral marketing thing yeah
and and the police freaked out you see
that picture of a SWAT team member
taking it down this was before the
Boston bombing too of the uh before how
did they make that connection uh it the
way they had the batteries in and
everything it looked pretty sketchy but
but yeah it's the mooninites right
from so yeah the convergence of all my
loves right there there it is it cost
the city millions of dollars that shut
down the city yeah it was like a huge
thing at the time they got a lot of
yep how much is a light
Bri uh I think it's an it's a good price
point there for entry-level toy the one
I sent from targets $13 13 that's a
steal
13 this one's
28 is this a big one though not
really it's 14 guess there's a lot going
on there you
know there a lot going on there in those
light brights I'll tell you 312 pegs bro
that's a lot of pegs hey guys it's Jen I
just want to do a quick review on this
light bright I don't know if this brings
you back to your childhood but it does
for me now my seven-year-old has one
loves it why is this their why is this
their cover video I want Jazz I want
Tech like I want swooping this authentic
mom giving her opinion I mean this is
this is the real deal bro was she paid
for this
endorsement
I yeah probably they don't disclose that
that's why I want swooping shots
clue I want produced by Michael
Bay
you know it's a lot different it's still
as she says inappropriate I'm not a huge
fan of the word in inappropriate because
it's not descriptive enough people use
it for all sorts of meanings you know
the phrase that I would say is that she
was doing things that could easily harm
children even though the children
wouldn't even necessarily know that that
they're being harmed or indicate that
they're being harmed this is something
that we absolutely understand that when
victims are being harmed particularly
when it comes to sexual exploitation or
coercion the victims often don't know
that they're being harmed sometimes they
have a sense of it but but not always
for example if you have parents who
expose their children to pornography the
children might not feel the harm they
might not go oh that hurts or that is he
saying not intentionally right parents
that expose their children to
pornography
I guess his point is probably
intentionally or unintentionally who the
like what the hell show us don't
show us No No Hoe ho now's not the time
man don't say
it was a scary experience or that
damaged me they probably won't I mean
depending on the circumstances uh know
that it's happening but you will see the
harm later on in in all likelihoods
particularly if it's a pattern and it
involves other kinds of experiences such
that you will see the child start to
exhibit all sorts of signs of the harm
that had been happening to them things
like being overly sexualized or being
afraid of sex or believing that they
don't deserve sexual boundaries and you
know there's all sorts of other effects
that point to Jesus people are saying my
father showed me porn what the
that's
weird people are saying yeah it happens
jeez Louise
man some parents are too open about sex
stuff well that's a difference between
showing and porn I mean I'm sure it does
happen Ethan don't apologize for your
grief I lost my best friend Gonzo I
painted portraits of
him through my grief I would love to
paint Shredder for you oh please do
I love all that stuff thank
you damage that occurred you know harm
happened to the child so that's the way
I would describe it is that it's not
inappropriate it's not necessarily
grooming because to me in my clinical
Circle we would use grooming in in a
different context what I would say is
that it's exposing children minors to
sexual content that very much risks
harming them that's the way I would
describe it where I was immature and
inappropriate with some of my comedy and
there were times when I did not put
enough thought into some of my fan
interactions and because of that
behavior people got hurt and I am so
sorry she says the word I am so sorry
that is helpful in an apology but I want
to put the notion out there oh
H why this comment The Zo experience
said Gary Klein exposed me to
[Laughter]
brazers
I am so sorry
smash or no it wasn't bra it
was what was the one team ski team SK
yeah it was James
SK you almost got a sponsorship with
them
my dad's out here getting more sponsors
than I
am dude that saying I am sorry or I
apologize does not necessarily mean that
someone is apologizing people walk away
only knowing that rule often times and
so they will say that well I said I was
sorry so why are you still upset at me
and that's all that they said you know
they said I am sorry I apologize let's
move on in life and and that's not what
an apology is an apology is it has 11
components I've already been over all
those things in other episodes but I
want to look at these um apparently I
did every single
one 11 components and an effect of
apology acknowledges the transgression I
did this acknowledge the harm I caused
you this harm take responsibility it's
my fault that whatever happened
sincerely Express remorse I feel bad
about this thing that happened explain
the cause without making excuses I have
the following
issues provide a plan to address the
cause I will work on that by if
necessary offer a remedy I will make it
up to you by eight request
confirmation of accuracy did I miss
anything request forgiveness do you for
oh I don't like asking for forgiveness
actually I don't I don't agree with that
point
why would why is that good because I I
don't want to put any obligation
on the person who's been wrong to put
them on the spot to forgive me I mean
they decide that in their own time and
Pace I
agree yeah what the hell
Kirk no just he probably has some
reasoning that he will be able to
explain the prime direct but I I I think
you have a good point there
request forgiveness do you forgive me
now I don't think so follow through with
remedy and plan Find meaning find
God
okay but just to go over him again you
need to acknowledge the
transgression like I feel B see what he
says about the uh the ask for right yeah
issues with this in the future there
other components as well when I say a
component of an effective apology well
what constitutes an effective apology
well the way I Define it is that the
transgressed upon individual will feel
as though the transgressor is genuinely
sorry if I were to hurt my wife's
feelings during a conflict or something
and then I apologize if I apologize such
that she actually feels like I'm
genuinely remorseful and that I will be
trying not to do that again in the
future and I have a plan I have a a
logical or a sensible plan about how I
can try to reduce that behavior in the
future then I would call that an
effective apology whereas if I just say
I'm sorry or I apologize and that's it
then that's not effective plus you
notice when I have the examples here
there's no word sorry or apologize so
with my wife if I heard F I could say
hey I just want to say that last night
when we had our conflict I feel bad
because I harmed you I I'm guessing I
hurt your feelings when I uh was being
mean to you when I said this this and
this and I I don't really have any
excuse I have a problem with doing that
when I get upset it's I'm not saying
it's an excuse but I have a I think he
needs to work on his apology I was going
to say this is like a c apology right
now
I I don't forgive you KK take it from me
and apology Kirk you got to work on that
brother you haven't been doing enough
apologize I mean he goes he goes sorry
if I offended you or
whatever come on
Kirk I was being mean to you when I said
this this and this and I I don't really
have any excuse I have a problem with
doing that when I get upset it's I'm not
saying it's an excuse what do you got to
head your bet in your theoretical
apology he's like I have a tendency to
do that sometimes and my plan is to
continue talking about it in therapy and
trying to remind myself to remain
differentiated maybe take a break blah
blah blah okay so you notice at least I
think I never said I apologize I'm sorry
blah blah blah did you just blah blah
blah your apology dude did you just
seriously apologize to your wife like
this anyway
enough enough with
you just say just say sorry I have uh
histrionic personality disorder you're
good you can get away with anything that
is true an iron that is an iron argument
trying to remind myself to remain
differentiated maybe take a break blah
blah blah
okay obsessed that is
horrible blah blah
blah he's like okay anyway let's just
watch the show now
please talk to the
hand I know a good I know your
brother-in-law's a or no your brother's
a divorce attorney okay you if you got a
problem talk to
[Laughter]
him Jesus Kurt so you notice at least I
think I never said I apologize or I'm
sorry and that's the thing I really want
to get out there and because of that
behavior people got hurt and I am so
sorry I never wanted to hurt anybody but
it's clear that I did and I feel so
terrible about that um I also feel
like so we believe her all the thing
he's missing or I don't know if he
addresses it but the ukulele video is
still up mhm where she's calling all
these people Liars
yeah so how bad can she feel yep and she
hasn't actually apologized to any of
them never reach out no so how bad does
she actually feel I think she's more
she's more apologetic towards her fans
that she's been gone for so long you
know I have a problem with these crisis
manager and these PR people I have a
feeling that a lot of these creators are
Consulting
with
attorneys crisis managers PR people and
they come out with these Half Baked half
asked wait you think Colleen was though
I heard a pretty compelling argument
that um from a PR person on Tik Tok who
analyzed
it that
um it could be like a
legal uh she's covering her ass legally
by not being specific that talking to a
lawyer I could see more so just because
I I the reason I was expressing
skepticism is I feel
like you need if if a PR person was
involved in this they need to try a
different career this is like this is
awful you know what I mean well what I'm
say and I'm sure and any PR person
probably would have told her not to post
the ukulele video too well yeah they
told they advised her strongly against
it but they never said
[Music]
she good point they never said don't
sing it these
kids I never
did
um people are saying I'm giving them
anxiety don't talk and chew at the same
time all right jeez am I I thought I was
being
good I didn't been trying I haven't
noticed it person but you know tough
crowd out there huh yeah very sensitive
to
the I guess some people really have that
sensitivity the my M Mis misophonia
mopon I have that you have misophonia
yeah misophonia well I I don't know if I
have the diagnosis but hear chewing and
smacking yes it physically paints me
yeah you have to close it well I I can
handle it I can get over it just Ju Just
for like a while but if I'm stuck like
on on in an airplane that would ruin me
when when you and I lived together like
last year or whatever and I would drive
you drive us back uh if I chewed gum in
the car you would tell me to stop yeah I
I ask very kindly to people I'm close
with but it's hard it's very hard if you
don't know the person it's a whole thing
to explain
yeah yeah it's hard not to come off
wrong when you're like can you
keep it down you cow a weird thing
mentally gum is way worse for me cuz I
know it there's no ending to it if I'm
eating a meal I know the meal is going
to end but gums uh bug me extra because
I know it won't stop makes sense yeah
Elliot says hello Ethan my friend Grace
is watching could you ask Olivia to say
hello oh my God hey Grace
hey
Grace what is this message thank you
hello Ethan my friend Grace is watching
could you ask Olivia to say hello to
Grace oh let's do the let's do it like a
play what does that mean you can start
the play and you can say Hey Olivia can
you say hello to Grace oh hello Olivia
can you say hello to Grace hello Grace
all right okay I need you to sit up and
enunciate a little bit better Ethan that
I I was wasn't believing that red
leather yellow leather red leather
yellow leather what do I have to do
around here I'm just trying to are you
mumbling the people in the back need to
hear project to the back
row Grace
uhhuh Olivia's got something to say to
you
hey hi girl there we go we got it on
everybody thank you thank you is that
Grace a was you I saw
you anyway
anyway let's get it on let's keep it
going here keep it there's probably
people who are disappointed or feel
abandoned I always wish that the public
figure would elaborate just a little bit
they almost never do to me it's like
they in their apology provide topic
sentences without writing the rest of
the paragraph because it's possible that
there's a lot there she says seemingly
in a genuine way it could be an act but
it looked genuine who knows but she says
I never wanted to hurt other people I
did hurt people but I I never wanted to
hurt other people I'm going to assume
that that's genuine I there's no reason
to believe that she lacks empathy even
though the internet seems to think that
half of the world lacks empathy it's a
it's actually a fairly rare condition
you can have empathy that is what did I
just hear eat my ex-wife and I'm also a
pedophile oh oh my God
Jesus all right dark didn't ask he needs
to and uh he needs to rate Boogie
apology on all fours that's what I want
to
see oh that would be pretty entertaining
that would be
good impaired or eclipsed by defenses or
circumstance or culture or something
especially given how much time that she
has had to think about it and the
consequences that have happened to her I
mean there was a good couple weeks where
seemingly everyone in the English
speaking World hated her that wouldn't
feel very good right so oh more than a
few weeks my friend oh yeah a lot more
than a few weeks
MH I feel like I could get him to ha her
I just need a little more time with them
well yeah in a way it's kind of scary
cuz he's like your normal internet user
not really like that into it those
people will not know how bad some of
these people are just on face value
which is kind of scary that they can get
away with it right
totally um rock city oh you're a rock
Enthusiast too just work my butt off dog
grooming for 10 days straight you got me
through it all now off to Ireland for a
week thanks guys all right dog groomer
get out there and shake your get
out there enjoy your
trip go
your dick and your hopefully you don't
have where is this going please I don't
know why I'm going there why would I go
there please he's a dog groomer I say sh
go out there and shake your dick in
Ireland hopefully you don't have pube
fleas but I don't think that's where
fleas like to hang out anywhere that'd
be crabs
right yeah not normally
that would be a rare
transmission yeah I've never heard of it
can you have we ever heard of that AB
where an an where a
dog pubic light or pubic fleas Jordan
Peterson would know what was the
question has a human
ever received crabs from a uh
pet
thinkal region was exposed dimly thanks
well you just yeah look into that let me
know
the
hair Jordan keeps talking over
you I'll keep looking okay
then she probably genuinely feel sorry
that she's like oh I never wanted to
hurt anybody but where's the rest of the
paragraph unless she provides it which
I'm guessing she doesn't I imagine the
public just doesn't believe I've heard
from professionals who work in PR tell
me that your apology should be very
brief and many PR professionals will say
you should never apologize and so I
don't
understand I'm with him that's I was
getting to is that
yeah I feel like the outcome is so much
better when people make you know uh
authentic
detailed and passioned self-aware
apologies it it it it's they Faire so
much better it's better for everybody I
mean obviously the difficult part is I
guess one admitting to yourself that you
did something wrong which I question if
she's ever genuinely done that I do not
think that she has I I do I still
genuinely think that she's just a
victim of a hate toxic gossip trade
mhm and so obviously an authentic
apologies impossible when uh when you're
not coming to terms with with that but
two it's so much better for the for the
person in terms of their growth and
understanding of so so much better for
the uh people who are offended so much
better for the fans who are looking to
reconcile their love for this Creator
versus you know the thing that they've
they've messed up that's disappointed
them and so I don't I feel that these PR
people are just not getting it I don't
think that they're like up to date with
the times
here I think like traditionally if you
look
at someone like Kevin spy let's just
take for example it's like how do you
deal with accusations of like
essay or other you see in Hollywood
nobody's gives a to watch Kevin
spacy sit down and do a long you know
uh detailed apology I mean that would be
crazy too I guess for him maybe in that
sense because
his relationship with his audience is
way less personal and if he's out there
being like yeah no I I was inappropriate
with a child I guess who could ever
admit to that that's kind of just GG
forever but if you if you're out there
like admitting to that on camera it
would hurt his career a lot more than I
feel like it would hurt someone like
colons also to a certain extent she was
publicly friends with miners like she
would comment on Twitter and stuff like
that right wait there's another Perfect
a seriously boogies got a perfect 10 A++
Plus+ good for my boy I never
did I didn't think it was that
good it was pretty
good
um I forget what I was talking about I
was yapping about something well PR
companies not they don't get it yeah
they don't get it I agree it's a
different it's a whole different
approach as a quote influencer or
Creator than you know Bill Cosby or
whatever dumb Army Hammer
eating a leg or something I don't know
he never actually ate anybody he said he
wanted to
right that's a wild fetish I want to eat
you
mhm that's fun up yeah same
lawyer as Colleen right Andrew we love
him we love you hi Andrew we see you see
you see you and Court girl Army Hammer
when he takes a bite of his dates leg
that's a 10 that's a 10 that's a 10 he
said something like I want you to fill
me up princess I think fill me up oh
interesting hey what does the ice cream
guy say when he sees my apologies to um
about the chestnuts Incident That's a 10
I knew
it I knew it am I the only one that
would you know even if I'm not a fan of
hers if she were to provide elab like
with idubbz for example I did a reaction
video to his his apology and I didn't
know him I only knew him because he had
guessed he had he was a guest on other
YouTube channels I watch he did a good
apology I remember he must have got a
good score what did he
get uh I'll check but he's he says that
he believes he was sincere and that it's
a good apology oh his apology was good
yeah so when he was apologizing to the
public he was kind of apologizing to me
and to me I thought his apology felt
genuine it felt like a repair it felt
like he was truly dedicated to trying to
make the world a better place or at the
very least not make the world a worse
place through his content like how he
thought he you know he evaluated that
his some of his previous content was
harmful to other people and putting a
bad influence out there into the world
for his fans to to follow in his
footsteps he he's like I I I don't stand
by those behaviors anymore and the only
reason I think the that his apology
worked on me was because he elaborated
you know he provided examples I also
feel like there's probably people who
are disappointed feel abandoned by me he
better not got a better score than me
though he
couldn't he doesn't have the Jan qua
required for a perfect apology there's
some he makes a list of the things for
an effective apology what he doesn't
include is that special something that X
Factor that uh you couldn't possibly
Define um update me with the idub
score because of my silence over the
last few months um and I'm so sorry
about that as well I I needed to take
time to um you make sure I I was
listening and learning as much as
possible and um I also needed to um get
the help that I needed to to be okay
someone said I stopped listening to
Charlie as much when he said idb's
apology wasn't necessary yeah I didn't
like I didn't appre I didn't think that
was a good
take like
$28 okay man seriously no matter how you
spend in this is a lot for some
cookies it's $7 a bag and that's still
expensive but then you also have to
factor in that the bags aren't even big
to begin with it's 4 oz per bag 4 o of
cookies for $7 is still a lot especially
when you compare it to the the product
that they're basing it off of and
supposedly approved upon those were $10
they're
expensive they 10 o more of product and
they were sold in Costco a lot of people
really enjoyed them but most people
didn't like the price that was a pain
point of that $10 for a bag of cookies
is a lot so $7 for a smaller bag of
cookies significantly smaller is a lot
too like it it doesn't matter how you
boil down this math all roads lead to
this being an expensive product that's
the BR ta that is the hard pill to
swallow there's really no way of
spinning this where $28 for a four pack
of these cookies isn't expensive it is
and to try and call people broke for not
buy it or not being able to it is really
some out of touch and the Really
foul part about all of this that my
little noodle will never be able to wrap
itself around bub you need them and you
are dropping trouser and in
their mouth right now by just insulting
them uh that's really about
it God damn that guy can go on and
on Fu expensive
cookies I get it man they're exp they
are expensive I I give you that you know
I mean that's really about it okay all
right fine we agree we agree they're
they are expensive we
agree Jesus
Christ um people are saying they want to
see my apology I don't know if any did
anyone ask for that should we do a poll
some people have said they wanted to see
my apology an
analysis maybe we should do a poll I
don't
know it seems like there's some interest
in the audience to see my perfect 10
your video is broken I mean his analyst
of your apology is four different videos
that's what I'm talking about bro this
man had the because it's like a you know
it's like analyzing the Torah or the
Bible or some you could spend a
whole lifetime studying such
Perfection you
know part four Jesus bro you made a
whole hourong Saga about me and that's
that's how much it takes to adequately
you know analyze such a stunning hey
deserving listeners brother now
everything depends hold
on atriarch oh atriarch also got his
rated that one probably didn't do
great atriarch and Ethan apology deep
fake
controversy part one let's see hey
deserving listeners a lot of you have
been asking me oh did you guys want
this huh why are there four parts
because bro what it it what's
complicated about that there's a lot to
analyze
I I
mean it's like studying the Bible it's
never the work is never
done you know uh can we do a poll though
because I I won't watch this if you guys
don't want to you know I understand that
we don't need to dig
up stop with the
Mutiny all right I'm throwing up the
pole uh do you want R to
hear we do have to save time for eel pit
though
too oh oh should I ask that do you want
to hear the apology or do you want to
see the eel pit no well we'll that's a
good that's a good poll no I like that
poll no we'll do the eel pit later
regardless I don't know if we're going
to have time I think it's one or the
other well no we'll do it later we don't
we're not going to do it right now all
right do you want to what so hold on
there's the Ethan apology Masterpiece
four
parts or or another one is the Oliver
tree Dar man video or or Roman Atwood
blackface that one's really fast I think
the Angels threw her down and made sure
she was not coming back okay so we're
what
Orman completionist hasn't donated 10
years of that one kind of old school or
Matt r
cancel Ethan's apology I'm trying to
keep up Ethan's apology the uh
completionist they just one up kind of
over that's like
old you know what I
mean what was the other okay what do you
have so far your apology and the
completionist thing what were the other
ones you show Roman I don't want
completionist okay he's gone Oliver tree
Dar Oliver
tree Darman collab I think that Roman
Atwood blackface ROM it's just like 5
Seconds long so we don't need to include
it or and fourth option four the fourth
option is Matt rif cancelled Matt R he's
a very popular comedian
dad oh oh I saw something about this
yeah Matt rif is R Fe yes yes sir
cancelled oh another thing I did want to
talk about is the uh Osama Bin Laden
sympathizers on Tik Tok
that is tickle well I only got four
four options here so oh really so wait
what are they then cuz we could probably
edan's AP it's too late it's
[Applause]
up
for a GM Shing
fortnite a GM Shing oh
that's
good
we
eveny a
fornite a GM sh for a grim shaking a GM
shaking
fortnite a grim shaking a grim shaking a
g shaking
fortnite a shaking fortnite woo a g
shaking
[Music]
fortnite shout out to the
family
fortnite
fornite
fornite the people have
spoken Ethan apology wasn't last but it
was second to
last absolutely nobody wants to see
Roman out with black
face although love a comment he says it
might be a good one to jeice can we show
that though it might be that was my I
was surprised to see that yeah that one
might be too racist yeah darn it real
bad it's it is very very racist it's not
even like a debatable thing like it is
just straight up race I noticed it was
uh
from 2010 or 2011 or something and was
was that like a trend then that's like
around the era so Shane's was well not
that specifically blackface seems like
all of the controversial YouTubers doing
blackface is from like a two-year
period you know what I think it was
before I was aware of the Trends on
YouTube at that time so I I can't say
but I have a hard time I mean it's
certainly nobody was really complaining
obviously if Shane was doing it for that
long with Fine Bros it's just I feel
like I I there was never a point in my
life where it wasn't like a widely known
thing that I remember even when I was a
kid yeah someone on my block dressed up
did like blackace for Halloween and
everyone was talking about how up
it was and that that was in like the 90s
probably right that's what I'm saying I
thought that was well established by
that time yeah no it for sure was it for
sure was it was bizarre but the pranks
in the hood guy I wouldn't expect too
much to care about the social dick
it's a prank all right I got a pee when
we come back we'll do the Oliver tree
Dar man uh as as voted on by the
audience this is a democracy or sweet a
representative democracy benevolent
dictatorship oh Matt R is a close second
though people want I didn't realize he
was super popular like that his name
that that would be a good
clip we got to do both I think there you
go and then eel pit all right I'll be
right back and then the eel pit right
somebody don't made $20 ask is the evil
pit even real it's real I
don't it's still real to me Dam what
does that mean it's real and it's
spectacular we're not just like trolling
here uh Matt R blocked me for a tweet I
made with two
[Laughter]
likes yeah sounds like he's having a bad
week uh I turned 24 today my only
birthday wish is for everyone to tell
Olivia she slays oh my God you slay
happy birthday to you slay you're
slaying you're
slay um you know what we were uh talking
about before the show I wonder are yall
in the audience excited for this
Napoleon movie where my Napoleon heads
out we were pointing out that uh yeah
Zach mhm we're pointing out that um
Ridley Scott he keeps saying in
interviews how he basically doesn't give
a if it's not historically accurate
and you're a nerd if you care about that
which is an interesting approach um
but the fact that he's so uncommitted to
the historical accuracy I do wonder if
we'll see him swim y oh interesting yeah
interesting but that that did happen
though I I heard somewhere I had heard
that it happened too apparently it's a
little controversial there's conflicting
reports about the swimming part of the
Napoleon Legend but uh a message from
Dan SW
love uh Dan
it's you dance says Peak Paul Peak Paul
what Peak Paul Peak pole Peak Paul oh
Peak thank you thank you you said thanks
thank you so much me PE Paul their name
is just Daniel swl 2
huh you guys ever just sit in your room
and think about the
hawk yeah dude I miss the hwk how's he
doing he's doing good he's back is
boring desk
job poor guy
yeah poor guy and he's cold he's cold
and we just got to get him out here on a
permanent basis he could be like a on
the show it just be next to you on every
episode not on the show not on the show
I think we can get him on the show you
know I think it'd be a good contribution
I love the guy B that was an epic shot
that was like father son kamehame right
there yeah I I loved having I I find uh
no I'm glad he was on the show I enjoyed
it it was a good time thanks for getting
my nerd references I it took me a second
and I remember the scene I remember like
it was
yesterday uh what else we got here uh
got my EAS cards today with Ethan's
credit card stoked nice congrats Ashley
you can we had a thousand of those
credit cards so if you still buy the
green ones you can still get one yep
it's pretty epic very good very good
those are limited so they're not all
given out yet they're still going on
what is this that we just s
uh oh somebody oh this is Zach's I guess
we talked about it earlier but here we
go we got the exclusive Zach
guitar uh one of one it's worth a lot
make sure you get that uh actually they
did put in a protector already didn't
they yeah they did I think com in a
protector oh that would make sense cuz
it was separate okay well get that
graded at uh PSA it's one
ASAP uh uh there you go Jasmine said the
eel pit is real I saw it on Tik Tok it's
on there I told you we wouldn't we
wouldn't lie where we make that up
from That's a crazy thing to just pull
pull out of your ass and make upit who
would think to do that yeah be very
weird um scooting on over
to Oliver
tree is Darman a
claimer um so what got claimed was
Oliver's tongue the end okay that's fine
so Oliver is a claimer he is a claimer
this man goes oh don't worry I got you
the pass and then guess what our
always gets claims by his
playable I'll tell you no claim is is
getting past Zach Zach has become a
machine at checking for claims like very
thoroughly he's the guardian you're the
man dude no you no you dude you really
are no
you st so let's see I don't know how
Oliver got
the two phoniest dudes online teamed up
to bring you the Sham
PSA 4.5 million views holy what a
bunch of
suckers let's
see and Oliver left a comment no matter
how strange you look no matter how ugly
you feel you are beautiful okay weird
inspirational quote there
buddy
loser cornball
dude um that's a lot of dislikes why
people don't like Oliver like on a
serious
note I disliked it you did yeah I
thought Everyone likes
Oliver
who oh right I mean everybody hates him
yeah that's what I
thought anyway here is um let's take a
look it's 30 minutes long so I'm not
watching this whole thing it's
so good it's good this isn't
cool that's
it what is this like power fancy oh no
you did
it Jesse you
wrecked stop over get off me stop what's
going
on oh J started it no Oliver did not
true
who's an Irish dad is this that's what
kind of parenting is that he just walks
off I mean could try to do something man
he two black eyes and a bleeding nose
he's bleeding these two kids are dying
that's his older brother tough it up the
old man no no the the Kitty's fighting
with I know but like what kind of parent
goes what's going on all right well
tough it up there's blood on the
floor
man um Oliver is not in this at all
until the very end yeah so like whatever
you could just skip to that if you
actually I thought his Cameo at the end
was pretty funny kind of hate
it and believe me it's not
over so this dumb kid stes making shitty
music his whole life and everyone hates
it for being ugly I didn't say that
specific I didn't say that I think he's
beautiful soul not like in a weird way
his dad looks like Bill Murray
Bill Murray yeah got that Bill Murray DP
on it's such a shame to skip all of it
what can I do it's 30 minutes okay well
here let me send you at least the Tim
stamp where he asked his dad to buy him
a
instrument okay sure yeah well so he's
getting bullied for his music and stuff
at school that's all you need to know
leading up to this he's thumbnail is
hilarious the thumbnail is crazy it's
the Saturday otherwise you you can
improvise when I was a kid we didn't
need all this fancy gear to make
music what did you
do that's some Keith Moon level
drum yeah that was badass hold on you
you're telling me there's famous bands
that just tap the wall frame tap on the
M man stomp some Mumford man things
were simpler back
then
can you at least make me something to
eat good one Oliver you know where
everything is you can make it
[Music]
yourself he's too young to be using the
range is this part of what you wanted me
to watch oh yeah okay so he's making
eggs this this is where it all starts to
come together we're about to make music
hold on that was not in real egg nothing
came out of it why would they use a fake
egg is a real egg not in the budget in
order to comprehend you're going to have
to break
some comprehend in order to comprehend
to eat the the theet is a real EG I
think is it it
is slowmo that yeah I will I will frame
by frame okay let me zoom in let's go
frame by frame
here so we're gonna tap it bada bing oh
oh oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's y
it's real that's a real egg it's a real
egg but the shell fell like that
technique is kind of yeah cuz he's an
idiot dumb ass shelling your ass all
right so he's cooking eggs I mean no
wonder is 30 minutes long why is this in
the
video I don't need to see this I think
he's about to get inspired dude hold on
he's cooking literally look at that
[Music]
smirk realizing can make music sounds
around he's starting to believe mhm yeah
whatever just give up bro you're hurting
my ears yeah looking at you is hurting
my eyes what are you a clown nobody ever
teach you how to dress I look like this
on
purpose everyone's trying to dress as
best and as fancy as they could so I
thought if I look as ugliest as possible
people would notice me which helps me
become an artist and look you two did so
it's already
working
that is the dumbest thing I've ever
heard you'll never be an artist and am I
still watching AB I you you don't have
to watch it I thought it was all great
wait what what this shitty ass video oh
okay what are you talking about is
beautiful it's we spent an hour on the
analysis of the uh apology I found this
far more
entertaining yeah but nobody knows who
Oliver tree is so I can't click with it
true it's so true I hate toak the only
people that know who he is is our
audience I'm the only one
talking about
him break it to you the only thing you
ever be is a loser the world's ugliest
loser oh these kid
psychics I'm excited for your party
what's the DJ going to play probably
hip-hop like Kanye West and florid can
you play any dub step that's what I
wanted I couldn't find any DJs my dad
even offered to pay 100
bucks I dstep a DJ for your party oh
right his
childhood no
dork oh they're down they giving him a
shot dude thought he was about to spit
in his face it's cool context because
you realize you know he was always a
playing set no I mean dar's kind
of dissing him pretty hard with this
character
ization like get a load of this
dork he annoying as not the real
kid the real kid is a sweetheart I'm
talking about Oliver dumbass tree yes
kind of
right all right so I mean he has to DJ
he's never djed before what an
idiot this music's actually pretty sick
yo this Fool's going crazy yo this is
hey yo who's your agent what's up agent
get out of here this is exactly how it
went down dude so dumb was that Skrillex
it was yo Skrillex made cameo in this
for
real thousands of people before why he
looks so different all right you have so
much older than ol of her tree wait he
used to have like dreads and all kinds
of he just look like a normal dude now
SX made like a ramp just a year ago and
he looks fine now he's like a normal
dude now yeah Vibes he did a bunch of
music with young lean from dub step to
step just
step the doy do people
before that's an interesting haircut you
have there young man thanks I'm not
doing
this I feel like the people ate it
up this actor they're going they're
going like dude you're style is
obviously so forced just literally for
attention like there's nothing behind it
other than attention
seeking freak like that's what
Darman is saying about Oliver tree right
now as a real person oh that's
Skrillex what or as cam pointed out in
the chat uh Jeff Whit it's it's a Hot
Topic Jeff Whit wait what that's
weird that's weird Okay gu get it
he probably has okay did he have kids or
something like what
happened well he I mean he's like 50
been 13 years right since he was like
the emo dubstep guy it's okay wor he's
doing a cameo in Oliver Tree video he's
down bad yeah uh no he's I'm kidding I
will he's successful right thanks all
right get on with it I mean what the
let's see Oliver the real Oliver
just I'm trying to get there but this
shit's so
DN you know I think that's going to
resonate with a lot of
people context that's when he's a kid
his mom's friend says why don't you stop
being a loser and get a job and help
your mom out and then he sees her again
in the future just so you know who the
lady is okay got it cut
her just getting
[Music]
started
I'm assuming this oh cuz of the because
of the door
frame successories are often
characterized by talent and hard work
not this time just dumb luck and all
tree's case this was also his unwavering
dedication to creating the very best art
possible from his humble beginnings
in Oliver tree went to become a genre
genre blurring sensation releasing
countless hit songs not countless we
could easily count
them should have said he went on the H3
podcast and the audience carried him
until he got big on Tik Tok basically
yeah that would be a good summary
yeah so does this all have his music
yeah God
damn oh there okay hey this is a great
video 10 out of 10 now again I don't
recall ever being consulted with using
my propri retary
footage like aren't they supposed to ask
for permission to use this this isn't
fair use they're using it identity theft
with you gotta be this is definitely
fair use how is it fair use a two second
clip in a montage about his life nothing
to do with it it's not transformed it's
used it's completely transformed and
you're not watching an interview with
Oliver tree right now hold the phone Dan
you are out of your element okay
this is not transformed they're
literally using it for its intended
purpose of
showing this
clip they didn't change
it they need to ask me for permission
and frankly pay me as well uh especially
when it comes to Oliver tree they voice
it over let me
hear I mean it's just what it says it
says go
ahead individuality oh he's wearing the
teddy fresh I
[Music]
can I can give him a pass for
that I'm I'm not actually upset for the
record I'm doing shtick that being said
I don't think it is fair
use be interesting though maybe I'll try
it maybe I'll see what the judge says
I'm coming after you Dar man scumbag
this is Unapologetic all
right
oh my god when can I
actually just a giant Oliver tree puff
piece
man we get it we get
it Flying Kicks yeah yeah okay all right
here here here we go here we go this
part's good we love this part I see he
came into the most non atttention
getting freak uh costume he
has well for most of my life I felt
pretty lonely and I think most people
tend to be lonely so I wanted to make
some hold on someone said you didn't ask
for permission I'm providing
commentary I am transforming the
footage
gabish for context that's his mom and
her friend walking out the everybody's a
lawyer now everybody understands f is
okay what do I
know who who walked out yeah his mom and
her friend so this is the old the old
bag that on him all right let's see him
give it to
[Music]
her enough with the music bro somebody
cares tell us about the new album you
have coming out alone in a crowd well
for most of my life I felt pretty lonely
and I think most people tend to be
lonely so I wanted to make something
that really reminds us that although we
feel alone we're all alone together you
know I think that's going to resonate
with a lot of people I hope so it's my
mom Christine friend Amy hey Amy how are
you good thank
you he's so fun he is actually so funny
in this the way that he does this whole
guy
thing we are so proud of you Oliver you
know my nephew he can't stop talking
about you uh maybe he could get tickets
to your tour of course we'll get him
sorted what's his name oh it's it's
Jeremy tell Jeremy I say hello
I'm show check it out you call that
music bro yikes yeah you're not making
it oh hell no not on give it
[Music]
back y all good man why are you dressed
like
that like a dollar store astronaut what
is this I'm
fine they don't listen to them they used
to say the same thing to me and they
still
do
look at this goofy look how goofy this
is y all good man I got to say his
acting is kind of fire though he's good
yeah I'm definitely feeling it I think
he's selling the scene they don't listen
to them they used to say the same thing
to me and they still
[Music]
do you're Oliver tree yes I am you like
Steve oi yeah talk to him right now wait
now
yeah what's up Stevie what's going on yo
Oliver what's up hey can you say hello
to my
[Music]
friend it's like he showed his dick or
something like what did you sh what did
you show him
Steve that's it you know wow sweet how
did that come to be I I still have so
many questions why does this exist why
does this exist yeah so wait does he
actually have a new album alone in a
crowd that is real isn't it yeah it's a
plug so this is just a promotion yeah
yeah I think
ultimately that's what this is so you
don't think darman's a big fan of Oliver
tree
naturally maybe not or maybe so two can
be
true here here's what I'll say about
Steve
AI bro I feel like I see that guy
everywhere he's like the shack of music
and I'm not impressed I mean I think
every person in the industry has
probably got his ass on speed dial and
he's the type of guy that would answer
too they don't listen to and I I say
that as someone who's nonfamiliar with
any of his work so this isn't a
criticism of his music or anyone that's
a fan of his because we love everybody
but what I am saying is that how much do
you see Steve
ioki in every goddamn
thing I feel like that was true a while
ago this is the first this is the first
time I've heard his name in five years
probably maybe that's why Oliver was
able to get him yeah he was the heir to
the Benny Hana Fortune right I was going
to say really he comes from like a super
rich family dad was a guy by the name of
Rocky Aoki dude I love Benny Hana oh
right yeah to go on my birthday
like I hope I'm not speaking at a turn
but I always had the Imp he's like
almost like a DJ khed like figure where
he's just kind of part not in like the
that he's a goofball like him
but the way that DJ is just like just
kind of collabs with people all the time
but he doesn't really do much of like
his own original stuff is that is that
accurate I see what you're saying yeah
it's fair to say yeah but he's like a
he's a producer right that's his thing
he's a producer yeah so is he a is he
and he's like a DJ and his you know his
shows are always wild and stuff he's
kind of known for his live act so is he
a a nepo baby then I mean if
his parents were in the restaurant
industry and very successful not in the
music industry but obviously being Rich
opens lots of Ben you know where's the
first place when I was hanging out with
with uh
Austin was it Benny Hana he took me to
Benny Benny hanas is where all the magic
there's quite you're underplaying the
amount of crossover that happens there
Benny Han is where everything mixes up
man just like that fried rice bro he
claims he didn't get a penny from his
there the onion volcano oh his
sister is an actor actress she's uh
she's in Fast and Furious seriously oh
my gosh that's his sister yeah yeah her
last name is Maya Aoki right wait who's
that Devon Devon
ioki ioki oh I don't oh do I recognize
her kind of so then what's the chances
that he became a
famous producer and she became a famous
actress I mean that's nepo baby
yeah of course obviously being born
incredibly wealthy uh like hey Sten
Spielberg I know a
girl she's my daughter give her a shot I
heard your next movie needs some fun D
Stephen Spielberg probably loves eating
at benas too you know who doesn't yeah
onion volcanoes and
I I actually don't recognize her
though she's from Fast and Furious yeah
too fast and furious I remember her Too
Fast Too Furious like the the pink like
leopard skinny jeans if you remember she
had like a pink car I think Ethan has
said in the past that he has not seen
those movies am I correct no I have
never watched a single one you should
watch The Fast and the Furious
movies
car oh here so this was her
whip oh yeah that's pretty far dude
these movies rip okay her car is sick
I'm obsessed with it I want when I was a
kid I literally wanted it yeah that's
pretty cool actually I'm not even going
to hate it well shout out to the ioke
Legacy he's found his way into this uh
star studded show over here at Darman
Studios
um shout out
to what was the city he got charged for
defrauding was it Vegas uh Oakland
Oakland shout out to the city of Oakland
believe or if not Oakland another Bay
Area City but I remember it was the Bay
Area yeah he's a he's a good guy we like
him he's a good
guy uh Blaze
420 why'd you do is that why'd you do
Oakland CU wasn't Darman arrested for
weed oh it was marijuana related in some
way or another yeah Oakland pot
entrepreneur charged with fraud good
memor he's tuned in I mean Darman going
from from selling drugs and defrauding
the
city into motivational inspirational
content is giving the same Vibes as
blippy doing a diarrhea on his friend
and then making kids
content oh my God you know it's just
it's there's something special happening
in that
pipeline well literally we're coming on
three hours should we should we do Matt
R real fast let's Matt R that'd be a
good highlight right I don't know
nothing about Matt I think it would do
really good on Tik Tok he's super
popular there give it a try he's very
young guy I noticed him on Tik Tok I saw
a few of his um crowd work Tik toks he's
very F I mean he's he's very good at
improvisational comedy I mean the views
are nuts look at this 65
million on this crowd Work video does
anybody here have any autistic children
do you really yeah how old um so he just
turned four he just turned four What's
um how far in the Spectrum would you say
he is is it little by little or is he
like he's non-verbal he's non-verbal got
he got it
yeah what's his what's his thing that
he's really good at um so he's
hyperlexic hyperlexic what's that he's
very very good with numbers shapes
colors he's good with numbers shapes and
colors yeah that dude about to rob
a
casino you're going to be a very rich
mom there's no cons bro you don't got to
worry about him talking to strangers you
don't like talking to
nobody that's awesome
congratulations what is that something
she some fan art you made that yeah are
you kidding me you drew this that's so
cool she Drew
this
a this is so good and you're
verbal
guys this is really good okay be
nice okay this is going top of the
fridge yeah so I think this is actually
a really great example to compare from
where he came to why people are angry at
him people have said that he he had a
heavy uh women based audience true the
ladies loved mattt R and you can see in
this one one of his most viral Clips
this is from
29 is
that that's what like a year ago is that
what it say February Yeah okay or no
yeah okay
whatever so you can see he's like he's
being silly and he's making fun of like
you know not really making fun of autism
he's doing a good job I think of
skirting the line I mean here this top
comments pretty good says nailed this
topic while still staying inoffensive
yet being still being Matt R and you can
see he's getting lots of love from the
ladies they're drawn in pictures and
stuff so this was kind of his Persona is
that he was
um a ladies man I don't know if that's
the right word but that's the vibe
there's more of them I mean he's got a
lot of that one had 65 million this one
has also 65 million uh let's see he's
still baby
mama well that's
loyalty it's 2 minutes long I'm not
going to watch the whole thing so he
just got a Netflix special that I
actually tried watching because I I saw
his clips and I thought you know let's
see wor the shot it it was like trending
on Netflix the number two most popular
TV show on that list you know I was like
oh okay I personally didn't find it
very funny um but you know comedy is
definitely in the eye of the beholder so
I'm not I'm not one to
like uh take my opinion on that too too
seriously but um I went to the internet
and I saw people are actually quite
upset over it let's
see um hold on there's a few of these I
want to catch up on what's the dress
code for the live show Alysa said uh
full formal formal or you'll be ex
exited yeah you'll be escorted out if
you're not in a gown or a tuxedo that's
aoke or something of you know equivalent
to those two that's a joke of course but
I'm we will all be dressed very very um
yeah and we're encouraging uh if you
have the means to uh dress up nice I
think it'll be fun if the whole audience
is uh kind of somewhat fancy obviously
you don't have tuck or anything but you
know dress whatever you want though it's
it's a big yeah at the end you're not
going to get kicked out no no no no
you're still going to be welcome thank
you for the laughs Jake said I'm in a
impatient mental health treatment for
for PTSD and major depressive disorder
and your show is keeping me
going
um thank you I'm just I'm shocked by how
many people are just going through just
horrible times people are going
going hope it's not because of the show
right huh yeah hopefully not because of
us probably hopefully three curse the
show is helping not curing right okay
good I just want to make sure I got that
right thank you Jake and uh thank you
for listening and I
sure that uh you're going to just you
know what I mean you got this you got
this buddy and we're here for you we're
not going anywhere kabish thank you up
forever and hopefully it wasn't the
podcast to put you there um are the more
people still around is that Kevin
K Kevin I don't know you tell me
punk ass
yo I'd almost say you know missed you
but
you are an enemy of the show so absolute
enemy of the show because a menace are
we sure that's the real Kevin I think so
might just be another Kevin no I
recognized the last name yeah yeah Shaye
Chapman says lost a quarter of my tongue
to oral cancer Jesus you
guys uh I know a little bit about that
my uh my dad uh uh had that happened to
him from cancer he had part of his
tongue removed and then he had a surgery
to graft on
tissue from his arm on his yeah it's uh
a thing is his uh voice the same as it
was uh he talks a little funny now um
but it's not too bad and over time this
it was six or seven years ago that this
happened actually I think it was more
like a decade ago now I think of it um
and yeah over time uh you know he did a
lot of therapy to kind of like retach
himself um he kind of talks as if like
you can imagine what it be like to talk
with a swollen tongue that's kind of
what he talks like now but he's totally
understandable and everything well he's
living and he's alive which is the most
important thing so so they said I lost a
quarter of my tongue to oral cancer and
I've been fighting it since June unable
to work today I finally got a return
date seriously wouldn't have gotten
through it without the show I love you
all wait what does a return date mean oh
for
work uh yeah I imagine so on yeah un
able to work today I finally got a
return date so I'm just saying after
seeing all these I'm sorry about all
these horrible things everyone's dealing
with I really hope the show didn't give
you the tongue C that was maybe just bad
luck or something I hope not to I hope
not to but thank you for watching and
we're always here for you and we love
you so much thank you guys thank you
thank
you
um so I was talking about Matthew
re um so yeah he put out his Netflix
special natural
selection I didn't think it was
funny has anybody liked it I've Just
Seen A lot of people angry about it I I
didn't watch it I haven't seen it but
yeah the
backlash I hadn't even heard of him the
backlash was big enough that people like
me that hadn't even heard of him were
like oh damn this guy is getting lit up
right now that's what's so weird about
this is that like he's become and a lot
of people don't know about him because I
just found out about him a few months
ago he's so popular like when he goes on
shows does podcast interviews whatever
you're talk you're looking at like
Millions views guaranteed this man was a
phenomenon um
and and uh
well yeah I don't it doesn't seem he's
getting top remarks for this standup I
don't know if people even s he was on
Rogan recently really
mhm that
probably got a lot of views eh I I'm not
sure how Che I'll check on right now on
SP can you see on I don't know not
onl good to see it you can see how the
highlights didn't and get an impression
but anyway like I said he's popular with
with the ladies and I don't think Rog
that um I I mean I don't know what am I
a psychologist what am I a
sociologist I know he's a h he's a honk
I was kidding he's a honk what can you
do this was my ass he's a h i mean he's
a honk I guess I don't know but he's
he's also it's Al not just his hunkiness
it's his you know his whole thing of
course yeah so he begins his set with a
joke uh that
goes something about how Baltimore is
ratchet he says it's both ratchet and
the nicest place you guys have to pick a
lane here's the joke he
said and we couldn't get over the fact
they went to a restaurant and the
hostess had a black
eye and here's the joke we couldn't go
over the fact that we're like this is
the face of the company this is who you
have greeting people and my boy uh who I
was with was like yeah I feel bad for
man they should put her in the kitchen
or something where nobody has to see her
face and I was like yeah but I feel if
she could cook she wouldn't have that
black
eye H but and then he okay I should have
seen where that was G and then he
follows it up though by saying like uh
oh I'm just seeing how fun you guys are
let's I'm just I'm seeing how you know
so again it's an old timey joke it is
that is that is a Jimmy Lee joke like
straight up kind of yeah right like
think of just think of that in his voice
and it if you could she could cook she
wouldn't have that black eye work with
me work with me I got my eye on you
right
yeah oh members go up his back thank you
my friend with 100 gifted sub holy thank
you love you buddy than thanks for
giving Thanksgiving oh we just did
another 50 oh boy oh boy here we go love
you full his
thing love you love you members go up
rler talk even lizy
baby so um again imagine the majority of
people tuning in are are women and so I
think that rubb people wrong in the
sense that one
it's not that funny it's when you say
it's an old timey
joke it's like something that we've
heard yes before heard a million
variations of that and and like yeah and
we look back and be like H kind of out
of touch but to bring that back is not I
don't know I get I don't get offended by
by standup comedy so much as when I see
something like that I'm like this just
kind of hacky hacky yeah like that's my
thing with the Trans things and again I
wish I got the opportunity to talk to
Whitney about this on the show but it's
not and I'm not trans so it's not my
place to say this is offensive or not
right but to me when it's like I'm
really another comedian on stage doing
trans jokes like it's just so
hacky bro yep or just like how almost
all comedians like half their sets these
days are about how you can't tell jokes
anymore you can't tell jokes anymore you
telling jokes anymore it was funny it
was interesting like 10 years ago for
like a month yeah a year at most maybe
when everyone was doing let's stop how
can you call yourself a stand-up
comedian do this hacky dumb
especially when we can we can pretty
much put that to bed right when like
Dave Chappelle still has lots of
specials and is the biggest comedian in
the world still that like you can't tell
jokes anymore you can definitely tell
jokes clearly even if it is true it's
it's like let's we can't we can't keep
with the same joke right even if it's
true we got we got to move on right you
know what I mean not that we would ever
run jokes into the ground here on I've
never in my life
frankly and I think if anyone would
agree it would be that uh Boogie would
have something to say in support of us
not ever running jokes you think Boogie
has something something to weigh in on
this never did oh he never did oh he
never did um
so yeah rub people wrong it's just not
funny I was like okay where'd that come
that was his opening line I was like
okay I mean all
right so was he trying to do like a like
a Icebreaker by being super offensive
and pull back from there or was the rest
of it hacky like that no the whole thing
was
very the whole thing was extremely uh
chauvinistic and weird just like sex
talking about like sex with the with the
ladies and I don't know it was very broy
it was very broy I think he's trying to
uh possibly Pander to a different
demographic I guess he said in a variety
interview he actually said I don't
Pander my career to women it seems like
he almost took issue with that he says I
would argue that this special is way
more for the guys so that was something
I guess that was pre uh
preconceived uh here's some of the
examples of tweets the way women
catapulted mat Matt re into popularity
and the second he gets a comedy special
on Netflix immediately betrays him with
a joke about domestic
violence so people are taking a special
offense because her his career has been
yes primarily fueled by a female fan
base which is and I think there that is
probably true to an
extent yeah that's a major component but
also the way he responded to the
criticism which we're getting to was
insane yeah we'll get we'll get to that
as well as
well again I don't think that it you can
joke about domestic violence I I think
that theoretically you can joke about
pretty much anything if it's done well
but obviously that's the hard part about
being a stand-up comedian right is right
is handling delicate topics class F that
is and it I Hank Green actually had a
really good take on this I thought a
comedian ruining his relationship with a
large portion of his fan base because he
wanted to be like all the other boring
ass nflix special you can't a joke tell
a joke anymore crowd is actually just
depressing and specifically we're
talking about like uh Rogan nightes yeah
you know they're all the same they are
all the same
person it's like they
all the
same com Joe Rogan is ruined comedy I'll
say it he's he has turned comedians
into this up silly
archetype of reactionary
losers that are both too
sensitive and also super mean
for no
reason yeah how bad do you have to PE
right
now uh let's see this person said I
think Matt R special is so bad because
he's trying so hard to prove to himself
and other men he's trying to prove
himself to other men through misogyny
it's desperate and sad fck looks like a
Glee cast member Obsessed the
he looks like yeah made of plastic just
like
GLE Matt R's the kind of dude
and I mean this with peace and love when
he's like 50 he's going to look like
Simon
Cal like I don't think he's going to be
able to age gracefully he's going to
his whole face up with crazy
plastic
surgery he's going be looking like
Mickey roor in a few years Mickey roor
looks good compar to Simon C man or he
could take the Bri Brian Johnson
route Mickey roor looks pretty wild let
me see I guess I haven't seen a picture
him in a while Mickey he's pretty it's
pretty rough
bro yeah but you know in the case of
Mickey Ro I think he's a good guy right
I mean he has a is he I don't know weird
ass Instagram account I don't know
enough about Mickey oh dude what is what
the yeah dude yeah this is how I
remember him looking it's like yeah he's
got PL FY but that was like Midway
through the transformation so this is
full okay I see Iron Man 2 Ricky his
career almost like came back like the
wrestler brought him back and then Iron
Man tube but then it just went didn't
happen
yeah also something that's so up
he doesn't look like plastic surger out
he looks like a normal dude kind of
here doesn't
he uh that's not the worst picture of
him
yeah no what what was that Olivia
that's crazy that that's him
wow he looks like my
Aunt Mickey shout out Mickey roor who
looks like he's just stuffed the bombest
Thanksgiving turkey for
my that Auntie Can stuff a Thanksgiving
turkey
boy he's my favorite
aunt auntie
roor
[Laughter]
oh yeah oh my golly G whiz dude holy
okay no comment I guess oh my
God we should have make fun we shouldn't
make fun well this sure yeah we
shouldn't make fun oh
no um what did you what did you what
were you saying
Olivia oh sorry um well to bring us
actually back I guess I just think it's
so crazy that his joke the punchline is
that she deserved
it right right so yeah yeah the joke is
that it's just offensive yeah like I'm
just being off it's there's not really a
joke there's no meaning in the joke it
doesn't it doesn't play into his
intelligence or his humor like it's
literally just mean it's just mean
that's the joke is that it's mean and I
I have to imagine the intent was more so
to to be shocking right out of the gate
um to sort of set the tone for the rest
of the special or whatever um which is
why I asked if the rest of the special
was like that but you said I mean I
watched like 15 minutes and I was like
I'm not feeling that you're out yeah
yeah yeah yeah but let's see
um yeah Drew uh oh Drew apalo went after
him uh oh you're busted now buddy hey I
want to talk to you about something I
think is pretty re relevant topical if
you will for those you that may be
curious my mentions are absolutely
flooded with clips from a very
specific comedy special and you all know
which one I'm talking about no
need to tag me anymore I'm good I
already have an astigmatism in each eye
I don't want pink eye either in case
anyone's curious no I'm not
surprised not even a little bit you're
telling me a man here's the thing I'm
sure that what she's saying is awesome
but I don't want to watch it for 3
minutes there it is she's funny I I'm a
fan I just you know I
mean I want to get on with it it's
getting
late
um
so I'm just kind of out on standup uh
comedians in general as a as a genre of
people yeah uh not I guess not as a
genre of people but um as a format for
comedy I watched a lot of stand up
growing up I was like really into it I
never like aspired to or had an idea of
wanting to do it but um but I don't know
I just watch specials all the time going
up yeah and uh I just think the format
is kind of tired I think it's like
sketch comedy and that it's really hard
to be really good at it it's like an
absolute unicorn to be someone that can
actually be on stage for an hour
Captivate audience with um not just
funny but also interesting content
there's only three people that could do
that for me Eddie Murphy Richard prior
and Mark Maron other than that never
mark maron's good huh he does more
storytelling and like dark jokes but um
he's very U much like realizing that
yeah these Rogan knites if you will are
kind of ruining it they are they are
dude they're ruining it yeah and two of
them that you named are not doing it
anymore so it's just kind of one of
them's dead one's dead the other likei
Netflix mov exactly Eddie Murphy boy
that is a that's probably the best
standup com comic of all time eh I mean
ab and I always talk about his specials
like all the time they're crazy they're
the best like the best I
think yeah I think standup comedy's
definitely at a low point right now than
it than it's been in a long time but
there some out there that I still enjoy
but I just don't like
I used to even go to comedy shows a lot
and I I I I guess Co is kind of what
broke the momentum of going to them and
uh I'm just not really motivated to do
it anymore I feel like there's got to be
a movement coming up soon where like you
know a counter movement to this Rogan
night that's infected the brain
of comedians yeah I don't know the
problem is that Rogan has turned into
like this uh King maker this gatekeeper
of Comedy that somehow every every
person uh that wants to make it
in comedy needs to go through Joe
Rogan yeah
um so there needs to be an alternate
universe where people that aren't Alpha
Bros that live on egg yolk and cow
Seaman can do standup specials there's a
lot of comedians I really like but I
like them like in podcasts I find them
funny like when they're just sitting
talking but their standup I don't like
it all I think that's what we're saying
with Matt rif his crowd work was very is
very good uh he's very quick and but but
I'm learning his
comedy is sophmoric I think it's like
basic and not that funny or interesting
it's it's a it's a different art it's a
different discipline entirely you know
what I
mean I I don't know but anyway he posted
uh to if you've ever been offended by a
joke I've told then here's a link to my
official apology tap to solve your issue
and then you tap and it takes you to
special needs
helmet look at his shoes man
homies wearing the wearing the fours
dude yeah it's specially helmet are
lightweight soft durable well ventilated
and offer unique comfort fit plus this I
didn't know this was a thing Medical
Shop I mean I know it's like a yeah it's
a it's a Trope but is the special needs
helmet real apparently it is it sure is
and rif says that y'all should be buying
one if you've been offended by his show
whatever he's he's he's doing the Rogan
knite thing he's he's trying to switch
teams I mean it seems calculated right
like must have somehow
just uh didn't wasn't happy with his
audience despite it being quite large
from what you're saying I mean that's
the thing is it doesn't seems like this
is the thing you do to get attention and
to uh you know even if it's negative
attention to kind of like get yourself
out there didn't really seem like he
needed that it sounds like he was wildly
successful super he was like the
comedian yeah so very odd to just kind
of do this out of nowhere I think that
ultimately
um um what's his name green John Green
Hank Green Hank Green had the had the
best take about it it's just he's ruined
I agreed with that he's he really is
trying to
Pander to a or I don't know a male
audience for some reason he wants those
men um yeah maybe his audience made him
feel like demasculate or something
stupid could be yeah maybe he felt that
way all the time and when he got the bag
and felt like comfortable financially he
just decided to go face a Mas golf which
too it could also be like again he was
on Joe Rogan and the just based on the
highlights we seeing they got a lot of
views it could be also like from
external sources like all these dumb
Alpha losers insecure little
manlets are making him feel like oh well
whatever you just entertain women I feel
like people with a with
a large female fan base and comedy are
treated as like not not serious you got
to make the you got to make the dudes
laugh so maybe he's feeling some uh some
forces from from these egg yolk
drinkers the seed oil boys seed oil
freaks exactly to uh to make the dudes
laugh so hopefully the dudes are
giggling out there brother cuz the
ladies
ain't and that is
that
thanks thank
you yeah I wish we had more Clips I
don't even know if we can show it but
some of the stuff he he went on to make
quite a lot of kind of it's stuff from
the special that'll definitely get us
thinged yeah
true well guys that that's about it I
mean we do have the eel pit but it's
five o'clock I got to get
going uh but that means we won't get to
it till next week yeah we'll do it well
because we're we don't have a show on
Friday we'll do it on Monday on Monday
so guys um
remember uh even though we are taking
off for Thanksgiving we will have an
episode up tomorrow for members that you
laugh you lose Thanksgiving special and
that same will be up on Friday for
everybody it will be switching from
member to public so everybody's going to
get a chance to see it it's going to be
a ton of
fun somebody said that was hilarious
when Mark Norman was on with Ethan and
how I I recognize him but I don't know
who that is is he one of those Alpha
Bros he sat with me for like a brief
second on right I remember that I wasn't
familiar with him either is he an alpha
bro I don't know Mark Norman
yeah he's got fun he's got like
some very neurotic norand but I guess
that's Mar Mark S brown
Le I saw a lot of people uh suggesting a
bunch of people that are good standups
that they still like and I'm sure it
still is good I I was just saying me
personally I'm kind of bored of the
format like the standup comedy special I
know what you mean yeah for sure plenty
of them are funny and I feel like hour
is too long the hour specials it's so
hard do 30 minutes I think you know but
it's hard to convince people you're
going to come out for 30 minutes you're
going to drive out Park your money's
worck it dress
up yep um okay so yes thank you
everybody have a great Thanksgiving to
all and
everyone and
um thank you to our members you guys
really thank you to all the people that
uh donated and subscrib love you guys so
so much for that and stay tuned the
Thanksgiving special will be dropping
on Friday for
everybody and we'll see you guys on
Monday so with that being
said last night we let the rler talk
even up my
baby yourap
so even I speed hitting the gritty a
grim is shaking for
[Music]
for a shaking
fornite a shaking
[Music]
fortnite
fornite aing fornite